e
me we'll start this momentarily my clerk
is out to see why you didn't get paper
copies of all the eight bills that we're
talking about today but they were
emailed to you and I had asked her to do
that so that with the Press of a button
you could print them all so cost you a
little bit of paper but you can have
them ahead of time and just before we
start and uh rep representative will oh
before we start I wanted to mention next
week the Republicans will have a caucus
at 9:00 we'll send that out we start
executing at 10:00 we're going to have
these eight bills to exact in the
morning then late morning we're going to
start the last three bills we currently
have so we have one I believe it might
be 11 or 11:30 then we go 12 for break
then 1 and 130 and that will finish the
last three bills because we have a total
currently currently of 21 bills I am
going to put on the afternoon to exact
the last three bills
if it looks like you don't want to do
that in the end then we can come back
another day to exec three bills but I
thought since we're coming to the house
three weeks in a row then we have the
February vacation that three bills
didn't seem too onerous for us to take a
little bit of time and exec them in the
afternoon so as I told the leader uh
minority leader I'm not going to just
pull that note that's on all these that
we can exect any time so I thought for
the sake of notice and publication I'll
tell you we're going to list it those
three extra bills not extra the last
three bills in the afternoon it does not
mean we won't get more but if we exec
them all and then I want to thank
everybody for all that y'all did to get
in the reports because they're being
submitted today so the speaker will like
that so he ask me where's your reports
from resources well we're giving them
all of them right today so watch the
calendar cuz those will be coming up not
this week but in the future on the
calendar so hopefully we'll be done
executing all our early bills and a
couple of non- early bills that are on
our agenda if this coming week we get
more bills well then we're going to come
back again and hear those bills
otherwise we're basically all set until
maybe crossover but um I can't tell you
if we're not going to get more bills I
just thought um it would be appropriate
to finish what we have on the table
because if we do if you're prepared next
week to do the eight three more is not
too
Alison would you give the caucuses time
to caucus if we decide to exec those
three bills in yeah I as long as I don't
exec them before the time I say we're
going to EXA and I'm told I have the
power and authority to decide that day
we're not going to EXA them and move it
to another day but at least everybody
knows we're going to so you can prepare
in advance so there's no surprises
everybody knows if we get together and
say look it's just not time or we're in
a major snowstorm and the people from
Coos like Arie uh Davis says I got to
leave so you know we can adjust but for
the sake of having it on the agenda
because if it's not on the agenda I
can't do it so unless I surprise and I
don't want to surprise so now you know
so that's what we anticipate in the
future we're going to miss about three
people here today I understand they're
all watching the cable of today's
hearings um and I wish that they get
well or their mother and father are well
there's some illness in our families of
our members so but they all told me they
would watch the testimony on the stream
live stream so if I could ask you all to
rise as we start this session I'm going
to call on my good friend the
representative to lead us in the
pledge the of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
liberty and justice for all thank you
representative
Darby and he mentioned to me that it's
like I'm the card dealer in Vegas uh
every week I'll pick on a different
person to say the Pledge but I do give
you a little bit of
notice so now I'm calling uh to order
the hearing that was scheduled for 10 HB
568 allowing subdivision regulations
concerning water supply and we have the
representative and Prime sponsor here
thank you chairman harb and uh good
morning everyone on resources and
Recreation it's nice to be with you
again um my name is representative cat
McGee and I represent Hillsboro 35 which
is
Hollis um and I come to you today as the
prime sponsor of this bipartisan bill
that has been perfected over the last
two years to allow local planning boards
the ability to request water studies
when planning subdivisions to ensure
water adequacy as housing density
increases in residential areas the
Inception of the bill came from a
constituent whose private well um
productivity had been adversely affected
when a 30 plus Housing Development went
in not far from their property this man
was talking to me at the transfer
station in my town in 2022 and his
closing point was that water is is an
essential resource and that water
adequacy affects um existing homes as
well as um the productivity of wells for
new homes in um in water systems and
subdivisions and I took his point didn't
know what to do with it as most of us do
when someone comes to you with something
that's really not the area that you that
you work in um so I began looking into
it and um and it we formulated it into a
bill which has come before this
committee twice so it's it it came
initially I was I happened to be out on
an emergency medical thing and I wasn't
here to present it the first year so we
brought it back the second year and we
had some input uh from the Department of
Environmental Services water division um
and they brought some historical
perspective to the hearing by telling us
that uh in the early
2000s the legislature devised a Water
Commission to look at water use and uh
water issues uh water quality throughout
the state and one of the conclusions
that they came to uh was that that local
um governing bodies and planning boards
needed to have something in statute that
asks them to look at adequacy and um and
F the future of a resource but how to do
it was you know nobody had a good idea
at that time of how to move forward and
that was their testimony from Dees they
said people didn't really know what
would be a good way to resolve that uh
keeping in mind local control and not
having a mandate so nothing was done and
their testimony was and I I haven't been
in touch with them this year so I'm not
sure if they'll be here today or if
they've submitted anything was that this
bill is consistent with what they had
suggested and so we were trying to get
it over the Finish Line last time um and
uh what we wanted to do is make sure
we're not mandating costs we're not
mandating activities we're just simply
explicitly putting in the Planning and
Zoning section under subdivision
regulations language that says local
planning board boards May request a
water supply study in accordance with
local regulations to ensure water
adequacy as housing density increases so
it's a very practical um statutory
language
that uh planning boards can kind of hang
their hats on to say in this instance
with this development that you're
putting in we think we should have a
good understanding of of what putting in
all of these uh wells will do uh to
local water
supply so that's the reason behind it um
there are other reps I think here to
testify maybe
not um but you can see on the bill if
you have it um that we have uh
bipartisan support and uh representative
Bill Boyd uh Rosemary rung
representative Diane
power um K Murray and Nancy Murphy are
all co-sponsors on the bill um and they
had some familiar familiarity with it
last time uh represent of powers husband
sits on a planning board in a a house
that's part of the co-op with Hollis in
Brookline and he actually supported the
bill and submitted testimony to this
committee last time in favor of the bill
um and they had input on the bill um for
this time one of the things that was
changed that was recommended in the past
is to have an exclusion that says that
the provision shall not apply to
community water systems or larger or
large groundwater withdrawal uh that
regulated under RSA 485 and RSA
485c um we think that's a real
Improvement to the bill we don't want
there to be any confusion about what
this is and what it isn't uh so it's a
very narrowly tailored Bill and again
it's not mandatory so that those are the
things I would like you to kind of take
away from my
testimony um let's see if I have
anything else here I'll close by saying
that as the competition for
environmental resources like water
increases in complexity simple changes
that allow local planners to apply some
foresight in their review of
developments can ensure that we don't
have new homes that require water
curfews we have had that in the state
and again Dees uh Water Division had
testified to that uh that there have
been some beautiful mcmansions and then
they could could not use the water
certain times of day because of lack of
water um or existing neighbors who lose
reasonable waterf flow from their Wells
after years of living in a home so we
should be able to protect people from
these outcom comes um the bill
identifies that the planning board may
require that the applicant uh absorb the
costs of notifying abutters and
conducting the necessary investigation
so it's basically part of a development
cost um if there is a study completed it
it isn't something that's passed on to
taxpayers um and so I ask that you find
HB 568 ought to pass uh when you do exec
it now that I know your exact schedule
um and give us the ability to encourage
foresight in planning that will protect
homeowners and home buyers and pay
dividends in better planning as we move
forward to rapidly increase our housing
stock in the state thank
sponsor representative
McNab I'm gonna be McNab like mcke I
like it um thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question sure um did you
was has there been in discussion of the
size of the development that you would
do this for like does it apply could it
apply to like three lots just the same
as it would apply to the original Bill
we we've had a few issues in Translation
in um with OS this year and um for
example the description I noticed says
this
bill I guess it says allows the adoption
of subdivision regulations but it says
that require and it isn't required so
the language is a little uh confusing
but to your specific question um what
was your point if you thought if you
thought of the number yeah the original
Bill said four and above and I would I
would have wanted that language carried
over I don't I don't really know why it
wasn't carried over but I think the fact
that it's not spelled out is an issue so
it was a subdivision of four or above
and we could would love it if you would
put that back in because it would that
any other
questions I have one if I may sure um do
you remember last year's bill number and
what happened to the bill last year um
you know I could find it for you if my
purse was here but I think I dropped it
somewhere outside when I was hanging up
my coat so um I I don't to lose I don't
have it do you have it will he has it
representative Darby um the bill was uh
HB 1483
for um and we uh retained it over the
summer um and um then I believe we
passed it uh well not passed it we wrote
a recommendation of future legisl future
legislation thank you representative and
thank you I appreciate it no other
Vil thank you Mr chair I'm just looking
at the online submissions and there is a
submission from a repes uh from a Cheryl
Howard member of town planning board and
who has concerns about impact of
development on their town so to get to
the gist of it it just said that it
would be helpful to provide some basic
parameters for local boards perhaps a
provision could be added indicating
inherence for subdivisions or four or
more Lots yeah so would we have that be
more specific in the bill I would prefer
it it it should have been in here it was
in uh the prior bill
okay thank you thank you Mr
chair anyone else no other questions
thank you for your presentation
appreciate
it so that's one of the online uh and I
know representative NAB wanted to get
into the record and then we'll ask for
the blue sheets from representative
Sergeant um the online were 10 in favor
sheets oh that's right I have another
speaker
sorry remind me later you give the blue
sheets uh speaking against uh Bob Quinn
associ is that better Bob Quinn CEO of
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors um so we are opposed to the
bill due to the fact that there is no
definition of what a water supply study
means um back in
2010 uh this legislature uh submitted a
a
report which is the recommendations for
appropriate roles of municipalities and
groundwater withdrawals um in which they
reviewed various uh possibilities for
these sorts of studies and whether or
not this would allow or require a
hydrology study which my understanding
of hydrology study is it's very
expensive it's also very complicated and
challenging to understand or is it
something that would require a pump test
but without some sort of this bill right
now doesn't really have any parameters
on it um anything over four units so if
that's the intent of the sponsor plus
any sort of study um the cost can get
significant and um we would ask the
committee to potentially just take a
look at this bill and read the report it
came out in 2010 and maybe it's
appropriate to really do it better to to
do a a a committee I know legislator is
not always thrill with study committees
um to look at um how frequently these
sorts of incidents takes place and
perhaps the best way to resolve it using
um both the municipality as well as the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and with that I
will end my testimony thank you any
questions for the speaker representative
Derby thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question
um are there
um you know 49% or the high 40% of house
households in the state get their um
water from Wells um and so uh ensuring
adequate water supply um uh of a
property that's going to be sold um must
be a concern of the Realtors when
they're you know when they're selling
them so what what would uh the Realtors
recommend in order to ensure um that uh
the properties that are going to be
developed have adequate water supply and
that the surrounding um properties that
um share the aquifer um are not going to
be impacted and ultimately reduce their
property values yeah so I think working
with the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and trying to
identify um best cases for how to do
that I think is appropriate um I just
don't think that this bill where there
is no definition of what water supply
study is um you might do a complete
hydrology study it would cost $100,000
or more and at the end of the day you
may not have information that's suitable
or adequate to answer your question so I
think that the bills need some work uh
and we would enourage I median sale
price of a home in 2024 was
$515,000 um yes the cost of these
studies are not going to be passed on to
taxpayers but they are going to be
passed on to the buyers uh of those of
those properties and we're just going to
be inflating the cost a little bit so we
just want to make sure that if we do
that it's done in an appropriate Manner
and one that um provides the best level
of information to the planning board U
supply representative NAB um thank you
Mr chair I have a question for him and
also a question for you so my question
to you would just be could you send us
the 2010 study or point us in the
direction of where we'd find it I've got
a copy right here I'm happy to leave it
okay um is it online somewhere is right
behind me he can probably tell you where
it
is okay um and a question to you is you
know he suggested understanding better
how frequently this happens in the state
it's definitely a concern in our town
and has been a discussion and um so I
appreciate this legislation and I wonder
if there if the researcher for the
committee um or Dees would be able to
address the issue of um of subdivisions
that have had falling failing water
supply systems or concerns about water
withdrawal if he suggested answering
that question I'm not sure if there's a
way to get at that data I don't know if
our researcher would have it but when
the speaker's done maybe we could ask
the representative of Dees if they even
have such a study yep and if he does he
could submit it along with the report
any more questions for the
speaker hearing none thank you for your
testimony would would you like to come I
know I don't have a pink card but my
clerk will make sure that I asked for
you to fill one
out for the record and members of
committee I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at Dees and we did
submit a written letter of testimony um
primarily referencing the work in 2010
of a groundwater commission that looked
at groundwater issues for the state for
10 years in the early 2000s um relative
to the question of the occurrence of
clusters of private Wells having
struggles we don't have a lot of
incidents of that but we certainly every
few years become aware of it and do
surveys of homeowners in area and work
with officials primarily in places like
Windam or places where there's a lot of
ledge and Hilltop developments you know
Wells on ledge on Hills tend to fail
more often than Wells and other places
where you don't have overburdened sand
and flat
topography and so the groundwater
commission kind of being aware of this
going back in the early 2000s from
Bedford to Windam and a few other places
came up with a study that looked out a
way where municipalities where they have
this issue could address it if they
wanted to to and and propose some
language that could be put into statute
that would enable them to proactively
get ahead of this um they they develop
their report they develop model
ordinances they're not Dees ordinances
it's a legislative commission's
ordinance and that's available
ultimately the commission which had a
lot of stakeholders representing all
interests from a to builders to
environmental stakeholders to
municipalities they while they accepted
the report as being complete and
thorough there wasn't consensus that it
should be recommended that it be
implemented so it was a report that was
issued and left for the future to decide
if it should be put into law or not and
so that's kind of where we're at right
now so if this bill were to pass it
would enable towns to look at
proactively at Water quantity issues and
and there's some tools from that Old
report that municipalities could pick up
and put into their local
regulations but that's it's really up to
policy makers at this point decide if
it's needed um it's not widespread that
we have these issues they again they
just seem to intermittently come before
us but we we are aware of some some
towns that have these problems once in a
while any questions for the
repesentative from
Dees representative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um with New Hampshire's experience some
wild weather you know over the last
let's say decade um in particular over
the last five years where gone from you
know severe drought conditions to severe
flooding conditions in um some of the
severe drought conditions um there's
been lots of reports and we heard over
the last uh couple sessions um you know
people running out of out of groundwater
um is is is there any um is there any
concern that without a um doing uh some
kind of a evaluation that we could
exacerbate those um those you know uh
Wells running dry during these drought
conditions I I can't say that I mean we
certainly have been in a period of more
frequent droughts the last five years
but that's preceded by 10 years of no
droughts so you know definitely comes
comes in waves and as you look at
transient climate conditions it's hard
to say that we're going to have more
prolonged droughts I mean overall we're
supposed to get more precipitation and
so to the extent these studies are it
might be that you that they not just
look at the potential for Wells
dewatering but how to develop a more
robust well and that's some of our model
ordinances that you know drill deeper
well ensure new homes have more robust
water supply as opposed to the minimal
well where you go down 300 feet get four
gallons a minute for four hours and
you're good to go maybe do something
that is deeper so you have more storage
it's more fractures and was more
resilient so you know that is something
that could be considered in over long
term based on transient climate
conditions have a follow up follow up
thank you Mr chair thank you for that
answer um Mr Quinn uh suggested that we
asked Dees about how um how uh
to um assess how you know a municipality
could assess the adequacy of the water
supply um and was concerned about you
know um Hydra rology studies which I we
talked about last year I understand are
expensive um does dees have a have an
alternative to hydrology studies to um
to suggest to uh
municipalities we do I mean often when
there's concerns at the local level
about a new development impacting
private Wells the first thing we need to
do is really find out if there's concern
and anecdotally you'll hear all these
Wells are going dry there's lots of
problems but we've learned over the
years you got to actually back that up
with information and so before we spend
a lot of time running around doing
studies and with that we actually go out
and try to collect information and do
surveys of existing homeowners that are
reliant on Wells to figure out are there
problems to what extent there are
failing Wells and then already we
receive on a occurring basis well
completion reports where well drillers
every time they drill a well have to
submit a report to the state and they to
say why they're submitting it and if
it's a replacement well for a failed
well or new well for new development we
can see that and so we can start
plotting from our surveying of existing
homeowners and also from the data we
have in hand why new wells are being
installed if it's because Wells are
failing we can see if there's problems
and we have excellent Statewide data we
have um Statewide parcel data so we can
start coloring in Parcels for existing
homes with a failed well new homes with
a new well and you can start seeing
where there's problems or there's not
It's always important to really
ground ground any concern with the data
you have in hand before you go crazy
looking at it for a problem so we we can
do any any
questions I have one thank you for
taking my question you say you have some
proposed um ordinances to your knowledge
is anybody adopted these ordinances
already any town no and I want to be
clear
although the department developed the
the ordinances it was at the request of
the groundwater Commission of the
legislature so they're not our
recommendations so so they're not online
but I certainly can provide them to you
um as far as towns that have done this
to some extent a lot of people interpret
current statute as enabling planning
boards at either at the site plan review
or the subdivision level to require
these kind of studies it's kind of vague
but some towns do this and I know
historically Bedford used to require
studies where there wasn't penu water
Waterworks water available in a new
water supply being developed um but
generally speaking no these aren't
frequently implemented thank you any
other questions for Mr Karen
see set your hand up it's a followup to
your question I just want to clarify so
um towns may be able to adopt the
ordinances that have been suggested in
the report but it's it's not totally
clear that they like would this
legislation help clear up clear up that
Authority for them to adopt it yes it
you representative Darby did you have
your hand up
no okay anyone else thank you Mr caran
testimony that's it thank you you can
you can step back and now the blue
sheets
yeah we have uh two in favor one neutral
and then I do uh have the online up as
well which was 10 in favor and three
post but I can say that when I say the
blue sheets if you like that would help
out I think just to keep people
noticed okay I don't see anyone else
approaching the mic I have no more pink
cards so I'm to clearing the hearing on
HB 568
closed and uh and
30 seconds or less will open the hearing
FN I don't know why when
representative done did you find out
say she's getting
so we're going to be starting HB
582 you have pink cards pass them
than
I think my clerk went to see if we could
get some paper copies of the bill so
I'll give him a second to come back
representative Derby when you you're
done on your pink card can you pass it
thank you
represent thank
you that means your presentation will be
short
so I hereby open the hearing on HB 582
FN relative the safety requirements for
operation of personal watercraft and we
have the prime sponsor representative
Darby to speak first
representative thank you uh chairman
harb um honorable colleagues of the
resources Recreation and Development
Committee for the record I'm represented
will Derby from Hillsboro District 11 uh
representing the welcoming people of
national award 8 this bill is focused on
increasing safety on our crowded Lakes
um jet skis um personal watercraft um
are uh very affordable um option for
that allow many to recreate on New
Hampshire's magnif magnificent public
Waters many of my friends own jet skis
and um the vast majority of jet ski
users that I see are
responsible some background um last uh
term we uh heard a bill on um a
different bill on personal water uh
personal watercraft also known as jet
skis um and we learned from the
Department of Safety that um with
respect to the safety requirements
they're treated the same as boats who
can drive them um meaning 12-y olds with
a uh with an adult present um the uh uh
PFC requirements um and they're they're
not treated even though they are very
different from boats they're not treated
differently from
boats um they uh however um p uh
personal watercraft for example have no
gunnels they have nothing to restrain
the rider other than holding on to um
the handlebars or other um handles or
each other on the on the um on
pwc's these have um many of them have
very large engines um 200 300 plus
horsepower engines are not uncommon they
have incredible acceleration some can
accelerate to 60 M an hour in um under 4
seconds and the top speeds of many are
over 60 5 miles an hour um they're
effectively motorcycles on water now I
have nothing against personal watercraft
like I said I have a lot of friends that
that um use them these are different
from um the statutes uh from the
personal watercraft um a subclass of
personal watercraft that our statutes
called ski craft which were regulated in
1988 um these are one to two person
watercraft typically people uh stand on
them or or um kneel on them um they're
typically Two Strokes a lot louder um
the industry subsequently um adopted
sort of built out a new class of these
public personal watercraft which are
three people they are much quieter um
and for the most part not exclusively
but for the most part people don't have
a problem with them on the lake as long
as the the the usage isn't um egregious
like you'd expect for most uh most
people recreating on the lake you know
share the resource as a personal
experience um I think people know I've
shared that I have a camp on Lake
monomac in ringe New Hampshire in
2017 um there was a 29-year-old woman
that fell off the back of uh was a
three-person uh PWC she fell off the
back um they were towing a rope she got
caught in the Rope um dragged and
drowned um so this you know there um
it's just an example of how personal
watercraft are dangerous and and need to
be um uh and cannot be considered the
same as regular
boats um I also uh you know people might
recall my testimony last year on um WG
surfing um this is not a wake surfing
Bill and in fact this bill does not uh
restrict um uh intend to restrict any
behavior
um but uh
what I mentioned was that uh WG surfing
is pretty common and what and the
egregious thing is that we see people um
on these um typically the threers
watercraft jumping the wakes very
closely very close behind people um wake
surfing it's not always even clear if
the people are on are you know in the
same sort of group or if they're just
chasing the biggest wave ultimately for
Thrill Seekers there's two re there's
two ways to get um um you know a thrill
out of a PWC one is going very fast
another is jumping wakes while it is
illegal to um to leave the water it's
already against the uh there's already
statued against that these these um
pwc's are so large that they can't
actually get out of the water but um but
you can clearly understand when you're
20 feet behind somebody on a on a um
that's WG surfing it's very dangerous um
situation this bill um brings into
compliant basic basically
uh re um drives compliance with PWC
standards um the handout that I've
passed out unfortunately I wasn't able
to fully um highlight all the sections
but I think you'll get the sense the the
handout I um I sent around comes from
two different manufacturers um of uh
pwc's um the the things that I
highlighted or started to highlight um
are the uh align with the um the
regulations in this stat in this bill so
one is um don't drive the uh don't drive
the PWC um after dark I think that's
pretty obvious um one is uh where a
personal flotation device when you can
get thrown off um it uh there adds a lot
of risk another is and this is the
important this is a really important one
to me um is making sure that the
operator is 16 years of age or older
what you'll see if you read through um
these handouts that I provided is that
the um un uh PWC makes it or the PWC
manuals make it very clear that there's
an operator and there's a passenger and
the operator needs to be able to operate
the machine independently um of um the
passengers and they even recommend don't
um don't operate the watercraft unless
you are have spent uh substantial time
operating it alone well in this state
you can't operate a PWC um by yourself
unless you have a um a a safety card and
are 16 years of age therefore you can't
get the required um uh training say
independent training under the age of 12
but somehow if your um if your parents
sitting behind you um which I seen a lot
a lot um uh you can you know drive one
of these things down the middle of the
lake um okay
so the next thing I'll mention is I met
with um uh Department of Safety and
Marine Patrol a couple of times um prior
to this both before I filed the
legislation and and also a follow-up um
assistant commissioner Edwards um to
Captain den leevy and the lieutenant
that's uh uh in charge of Marine Patrol
um I adjusted the language based on uh
their recommendations for safety and I
got um agreement from the Department of
Safety that this is a bill focused on
safety that this is not a bill um that
restricts Behavior it is uh focused on
safety yesterday um Captain Dunley
provided me statistics um uh that I I'm
sure he can provide them to the
committee or I can uh statistics that
show over the last Dozen Years or eight
years or something that there's um been
PWC accidents every year and there's
been injuries most years um including uh
fatality um the now I am a member of
this committee I know we just itl
a a bill on a um wearing personal
flotation devices for kayakers based on
personal responsibility and I recognize
personal responsibility is an important
aspect of New Hampshire's culture um but
this um but pwc's risk the safety of
others I'll give you just a couple of
examples as briefly as I can you know
imagine that a 12-year-olds um uh riding
uh with their parent behind them through
heavy traffic lots of lots of turbulence
they lose their balance a little bit um
accelerate um parent falls off uh they
go into another vessel another is you
know somebody puts on some aftermarket
lights um you know the same times that
you can just sort of screw on so that
they can ride after um dark
legally and they're cruising around um
cruising down a lake at 50 miles an hour
which is legal on all lakes except when
of is saki and another boat's passing by
they surely don't expect a small
watercraft going at that speed they
misjudge the distance you know um
catastrophe another is you know related
to the example I provided earlier jet
ski um you know jumping the Wake behind
a wake Surfer uh lose control because of
the very large wakes that uh these um
that these produce the wakes surfing
produces um the uh wake Surfer happens
to fall at the same time catastrophe
these These are you know these are not
these are easy to imagine scenarios
everything I just said that this bill
will help to um retain or support this
um we say a lot that um the co the key
to um uh to save flakes is education and
I think that this bill will actually
promote education why because when you
have statutes on the law um the Marine
Marine Patrol can stop somebody not to
issue a ticket but to say
um the um law uh has been changed now
you have to wear a a p a PFD when um
when you're rioting rather than just
have it in the compartment in the front
um you know please do that in the future
or you know you're rioting after dusk I
know it's still Twilight but you really
can't do that these are the types of
things that they can stop people um and
uh uh not to issue tickets but just to
inform that um I think they'd be less
able to do without this legislation at
the end of the day um
we P there was uh Common Sense
legislation passed on skcraft uh in the
80s like I mentioned and this update
will um keep up with changes in modern
equipment um and of course I'd be happy
with in in the um in the goal of
personal responsibility if this
committee said that they wanted to re
eliminate the requirement to our PFD
okay that's fine with me I'd be happy to
take that Amendment and leave the rest
of it in there I'm H uh thanks very much
happy to take any
questions representative
Sergeant thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
essentially would you agree that this
proposed legislation simply expands RSA
27074 which currently governs ski craft
to a larger device that didn't exist in
the 80s when ski craft legislation uh
was enacted well that that's thank you
for the question uh that's a pretty
delicate subject um we had a bill that
did that last time and what it ended up
doing was Banning ski uh pwc's or there
was a concern about banning pwc's in on
a large number of water bodies and also
open up opening up um the um um the uh I
forget the petition system to ban pwc's
on B bodies this is not intending to ban
pwc's at all um so um this is a safety
requirement only and it is narrowly
focused on uh a few safety re
requirements thank you Mr chairman uh I
guess my point was this language that
you're proposing uh including on the
personal flot flotation devices just
mirrors what's already in law governing
the smaller vessels yes thank you um for
the question that's exactly the intent
the um uh when the that statute was
written um the they looked at Common
Sense legislation um
which uh is modeled here because the
devices are very
similar any other questions for
representative Darby representative NAB
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so are there currently any
statutes around miners have to wear
having to wear a PFD on these
craft does the 16-year-old already have
to wear a PFD I I I should have read
this I I think Captain dun Le is here he
can tell you for sure okay um because
they do in a kayak um yeah yeah there's
some there is some restriction for for
minors okay thank you anyone else anyone
else
knew no one knew representative Sergeant
thank you Mr chairman last question RSA
270 colon 74 hyphen C personal
watercraft already regulates personal
watercraft in terms of how close it can
go to some Shores on some bodies of
water is that correct yes thank you that
was actually in my testim I just skipped
over that's that's a very good point
pwc's are already defined in statute so
this doesn't introduce a new definition
um I forget the the year it was uh 2018
2020 something like that that they were
added um in some of the some of the
estuaries um uh to restrict um you know
to restrict where pwc's could go but
that um it doesn't Define the safety
requirements for them but it does like
you um uh like you mentioned already
Define pwc's so this isn't introducing a
new term thank you for the
question assume no other
questions thank you representative for
your testimony thank you all very much
for your attention next I have John woy
and Judy grimas they represent the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
my name is jod gmis I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association and with me I have
John Wally who is the president of the
New Hampshire Marine trades Association
so maybe John can give the statement and
then I'll go into the details of the
Bill thank you Jody good morning
everybody good morning Mr chairman
member of the committee my name is John
Wally I'm the president of the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association the
New Hampshire R Trad Association is a
Statewide organization dedicated to
protecting the rights of recreational
boers enhancing B culture and tourism in
the city of New Hampshire and
maintaining the stewardship our clean
Waters I come before you to an
opposition of House Bill 582 I want to
make it clear that the New Hampshire
Marine trades Association is for Public
Safety and we have supported many bills
in the past regarding P personal fation
devices but find this one
unnecessary we recently discussed this
bill with in our membership and many of
us our jobs are on the water every day
in the summertime found it very
surprising that this is even a conf
ation because no one can remember anyone
on a personal watercraft not wearing a
personal flight personal flotation
device um we also meet with the New
Hampshire Department of Safety each year
and it's never been brought to our
attention this was either a problem or a
concern um we have asked for some data
we have found that there was very little
to uh to back up anything at all um the
change in this definition of a bill
concerns us and Jo will speak to this
more in detail but in the state of New
Hampshire as representative Dar
mentioned a watercraft with a capacity
of few passengers more is considered a
boat and regulated that way and always
has
been we strongly believe in BHA
education in the handbook distributed by
the state of New Hampshire of voting
laws and responsibilities it is
recommended that an operator or personal
watercraft be equipped with a lanyard
type engine cut off switch and that
attachment to his or her person's a
clothing oror life
jacket by my observations every day at
work um like I mentioned before
operators of personal watercraft take
their safety of their passengers and
themselves very seriously and if you
were to do any type of a Google search
with the word personal watercraft they
would demonstrate every person on a
watercraft wearing a personal flotation
device um if this committee finds that
there is an issue when it comes to
Public Safety uh the New Hampshire
Marine change Association would be happy
to assist in education campaigns um we
already do so in the past regarding WG
surfing and other issues uh with our New
Hampshire Marine Patrol the New
Hampshire Association of of public
broadcasters and other uh National
Building Partners um we find that this
bill pleased to be inexpedient to
legislate um to answer a few questions
that were brought up momentarily in the
state of New Hampshire ages 13 years and
younger are required to re life vests on
any
vessel um there is 150 foot safe passage
Bill already on place when it comes to
passing other votes so IE when you're
talking about wake surfing and jumping
waves regardless of WG surfing boats any
boat makes a WG and if you want to jump
it you need to be 150 ft back from that
vessel to be regarded as doing it
legally which is already illegal as it
is and
lastly uh any parent with I would hope
common sense that would allow their
child to drive a personal watercraft
ahead of them would detach the safety
lanyard from their child and put it on
themselves so that the adult fell off
the life jacket off their personal what
the personal the P personal
watercraft the machine would die and the
child would not continue to drive down
the lake alone so again more common
sense than anything else but those are
limitations to the watercraft when you
clip it to yourself and all life checks
typically have a clip sewn into them
that attaches the lanyard to it so that
directly thank you let's hold our
questions until uh Miss scbl also gets
to talk and then you can ask all the
questions to both of them uh Jody sure
I'm just going to go through the bill
and kind of give you our perspective on
each each section um the reason why we
believe this bill is unnecessary um the
first section of the bill lines three
through five is that definition of
personal
watercraft um it's a Statewide
definition of personal watercraft it's
different than the carve out that's for
the Sea Coast you'll notice the language
in that section is just for that section
regarding the Hampton
Estuary similar legislation to adopt a
Statewide definition of personal
watercraft has been has been defeated in
this legislature for over 30 years it
came in 11 times between
1991 in
2003 um personal watercraft has always
been classified the same as every other
boat and there's a reason for that
because for those who have been on this
committee for for a number of years to
Define it means you'll there'll be
opportunities to restrict it so we're
we're very concerned about that
Statewide definition of personal
watercraft because as we saw last year
then there are bills to therefore
restrict or ban Public
Access we believe the existing laws
address boating safety already um again
currently all boating safety laws for
every other vessel apply to these
personal watercraft Marine Patrol cited
data um in a senate hearing a couple
weeks ago that according to the Coast
Guard reports New Hampshire has boasted
the best safety record in terms of
fatalities per 100,000 registered voters
in the nation for 13 years we should be
proud and I do have the statistics that
that representative Derby spoke about um
which I'll pass out for the commity we
can talk about um there's not a lot of
data specifically about personal
watercraft but we do have what the
department of safety gave us last night
in the past six Summers there's been 26
total accidents on personal water craft
and ski Craft um in one instance there
was no life vest because it actually
says it on the on the statistics um out
of 26 over six years we have over a
100,000 boats registered each year that
does not include boats that come in from
other states as well as all of the
paddlecraft that are out on our water
bodies as well so we do have a lot of we
we're it seems like the voting laws we
have now are working well
um again that definition of ski craft
was 1988 the bans and restrictions on
ski craft came over probably the bulk of
them came in the first few years after
that into the early 90s approximately
50% of New Hampshire waterways are
closed to those craft so we do get
worried about bills that seem to Define
because the next step is that
restrictions in ban now specific to the
provisions of the bill um you'll go down
kind of it's the RSA 27 74d is the new
section um the first letter a is that um
you can only operate the person
watercraft if the person is 16 age of or
older again as representative Derby said
to operate any boat over 24 25
horsepower in New Hampshire you have to
have your boating safety card and you
have to be 16 there is a provision in
the law that allows for a younger person
a child 12 14 50 whatever um to go along
to operate with a adult behind them
according to that law that adult has to
take liability and responsibility for
that operator in essence when it was
passed and discussed and I think it was
200 something um it might have been
earlier than that it was about kind of
the culture of parents teaching kids how
to operate um so what we're saying here
is that the parent of the 12-year-old
can still learn to operate
that 25 foot center console in the Sea
Coast with a parent but you couldn't
have that parent teach their child about
how to operate a personal watercraft so
I guess my question would be if that's
an issue of of of allowing children to
be taught by parents or adults then we
should look at that for all boats not
one particular type if we don't want
parents teaching kids if that's not the
culture that we want to promote then we
should take that away for all boats not
just personal water
craft the second letter B um talks about
not operating between sunset and sunrise
again there are no lights manufactured
on Persona
watercraft just like there are no lights
on other types of boats aluminum fishing
boats with a 30 horsepower engine on
them don't have lights either if we want
to ban aftermarket parts on boats that
are not manufactured with lights I'd
rather see that in a separate bill where
you talk about that for all boats not
one one particular type we have surveyed
our membership nobody nobody retrofits a
craft with lights there's too much
liability they do not do it the Marin is
have total list they're not doing that
they don't so it's somebody going to a
hardware store and getting the stick
them lights and putting them on but if
there is a whole page which I have here
somewhere of rules on the proper
equipment and lighting through our
safety rules um if we want to make sure
that nobody is doing that for any boat
that doesn't have lights on them that's
a discussion but I don't think you
should do it for just one
type c um is the issue about personal
flotation devices again I think what
we've seen and the data on the accident
statistics have shown that out of 26
accidents one had no life Fest and three
were unknown it's very common for people
to wear their life vest because again
they typically attach it's it's
something that's called best practices
um um very practically speaking people
vote responsibly and it's very rare to
see somebody without one again if you
want to have a discussion about
mandatory life jackets for all voters
that's a different discussion that's a
different Bill we'd ask you not to just
create it for this
craft finally there is the provisions
relative to careless and negligent
operation weaving in and out or swerving
at the last moment to avoid Collision I
would just note for this committee that
um we think it's overly
prescriptive um having just careless
negligent and Reckless operation on the
statutes is already there in fact this
legislature um revised those statutes
last year uh they just went into effect
January 1st 2025 there is a careless
negligent operation of boat statute
which was just adopted um it went
through criminal justice last year um
that's already on the books which also
have a reckless operation that is on the
book as of J 1 2025 they were there
before but they were modified last year
and they were passed so we think there's
existing laws to deal with folks who are
acting inappropriately again if you are
swerving or weaving through congested
traffic you're probably not don't have
150 ft distance on both side of the
craft if you're slam if you're stopping
before you hit somebody you're probably
again uh up against those um operation V
violations so lastly we would just say
the real issue here is enforcement of
our current laws um we think ensuring
adequate Marine Patrol is the best thing
um I started doing this work in 1995 I
think we had about 65 Marine Patrol
officers then um I remember wanting to
hopefully get us to 75 I think now we're
down to 25 that's the problem that's the
problem so um and I would just point out
that representative Derby has another
bill House Bill 397 seeking to address
the Marine Patrol Workforce issue and
house criminal justice we would support
that so we do not support this
legislation because we do not think it's
necessary we think current laws cover it
and we're very concerned about that
Statewide definition thank you thank you
questions for either of the speakers and
could you address who you wish to put
to I don't see any hands that's and
testimony will be passed out well thank
you both for your
testimony also an
opposition Jake Dila of dilver
Motorsports
Jake good morning my name is Jake D
Silva of Meredith New Hampshire I'd like
to start off by saying thank you for
giving me the time today to explain why
I oppose House Bill
582 I recognize some of you from last
year when I came to oppose House Bill
1562 which changed the definition of PWC
and sought to ban and restrict them from
public
Waters this bill while it doesn't go as
far is something we don't believe we
need my family and I own multiple
businesses that could be impacted by
House Bill
582 disable Motorsports has been a New
Hampshire business for over 25 years
with two PWC dealerships in New
Hampshire as well as a PWC rental
business to S Motorsports services and
sells over 1,000 pwc's a year our PWC
dealerships are in Hamstead in Molen bro
New Hampshire through the pandemic we
understood how important it was for
outdoor recreation where people could
engage alone or within their Inner
Circle results from a recent Penn State
study indicate that nearly half of
adults from across the United States now
participate in Recreation on at least a
monthly basis and approximately 20% may
be new to outdoor recreation during the
pandemic pwc's open the door for so many
families to get out on the water and
enjoy the beautiful state we live in and
participate in outdoor recreation people
have invested in purchasing pwc's
knowing their current classification as
boats they follow all the same rules and
regulations as other boats House Bill
582 would change that and treat them
like ski craft as you heard ski ccraft
are very limited to the bodies of water
they can access we oppose a new
classification of personal
watercraft that they have been regulated
as boats for over 30 years and should
continue to be we do not want to open up
the year-long debates over access of
these
watercraft um pwcs contribute to over
30% of new sail and boat registrations
in the state of New Hampshire we
reclassify pwc's The Next Step will be
attempted bans and restrictions like we
saw last
year that would result in a decline in
our sales and tourism there is no need
for this bill there is no need to
reclassify personal watercraft I spend
most of my spring summer and fall days
um out on the lakes of our state between
wiip to Arlington Pond Big Island
Pond and I can truthfully say I don't
see anybody operate as we've all said
without a p uh a life vest or uh PF
um as John already stated you know if I
grew up with my father and Uncle
bringing me out on watercrafts and me
driving them and they would put the
lanyard onto them compared to me having
the control um there would be seidu and
Yamaha and other manufacturers have
different modes for if you let somebody
operate the machine that should
not have as much experience it's called
a learning key or learning mode to limit
the speed so they don't have full power
as if I was just operating the Machine
by myself um so as we've all said I do
think that uh there is no need to to
change the law um and please oppose
House Bill
582 thank you any questions for Mr
Dila seeing none thank you for your
testimony also opposed to the bill Lisa
Sports good morning thank you for giving
us the opportunity to speak today
regarding HB 582 my name is Lisa miles
one of the owners of HK Powersports with
locations in hookset and lonia I live in
the town of Meredith on lake winaki and
I'm here to oppose HB
582 this proposed bill would change how
uh pwc's are regulated in the state of
New Hampshire today three passenger
watercraft which are 90% of the pwc's
that are sold and registered in New
Hampshire are classified and regulated
as boats and fall under all these laws
that I think are already
covered one and two passenger smaller
crafts are legally defined as ski craft
in New Hampshire and make up a very
small number I'd like to point out that
three-seater pwc's make up approximately
30% of new boat sales in New Hampshire
which is a significant amount pwc's are
popular because they are affordable low
maintenance easy to operate and easy to
transport and store most customers buy a
personal watercraft instead of a boat
because it's an affordable option to get
their family out on the lake others
purchase them for fishing visiting sandb
bars or restaurants Towing their kids on
tubes or teaching their kids how to
water ski pwc's are very safe and have
no risk of propeller injuries and are
easy to get in and out of the water on
in 2023 our stores alone sold over 600
personal watercraft to families to use
on New Hampshire Lakes at an average
price of only around
14,000 changing our laws to create a new
definition of pwc's different than boats
is very troubling we had this debate
last year and this committee voted it
down this bill will reopen the debates
over bans and restrictions that we had
last year and that my parents also
fought for in the 90s we thought those
days were over but it seems that we are
rehashing out old debates it continues
to confuse our customers and the voting
public
finally we have not observed any Trend
and safety concerns that were discussed
by the sponsors in fact we observe
everyone on personal watercraft wearing
their life jackets whereas people
operating larger boats do not um I'd
like to also point out that although
I've never seen someone not wearing a
life jacket there's no space on a jet
ski or a three passenger to actually
store life jackets so you have to wear
it
um when we sell personal watercraft we
always sell life jackets and obviously
tell people the importance and the laws
about wearing their personal flotation
device um as far as lights we absolutely
do not put lights on personal watercraft
they are not manufactured with them um
no one has even asked for us to add
lights to their personal watercraft so I
see that as a non-issue um to jod Point
situation
um as far as what
um Jake and I think John said these
watercrafts are manufactured with um
restrictive keys so that people that are
learning how to drive them you put the
key or you put it in the mode where it
restricts the speed to
50% um
also because these are classified under
boats keep in mind that a 10 12y old can
also operate a 50 foot boat with their
parent on board versus a kid sitting in
front of their parent operating the ski
where their parents are right here if
anything happened they're also
manufactured with what the manufacturers
call brakes and although they are
different than Brakes in an automobile
you have a brake on The Handlebar so you
accelerate with one throttle and you
grab the other one and it it these
probably have the quickest stopping
power of any boat on that is
manufactured so um the manufacturers
take safety very seriously with creating
these um does anyone have any other
questions about personal watercraft any
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you the
anyone
yes we got that don't have names on them
and I just wanted to know who they were
you is there anyone else to speak on HB
582 FN anyone else to speak on 582
FN representative Sergeant blue sheets
and
online thank you seeing no one else and
here in the blue sheets and online I'm
declaring the hearing on HB 582 FN
closed thank you moving right or wrong
11 call the order the hearing on HB 595
FN relative to Coastal resilience zones
I have two pink cards here and neither
one appear to be any of his prime
sponsors is um representative Muse are
bill I am not the prime sponsor but I
can introduce the bill and hopefully
he'll get here oh is this the prime
here I have mine because I printed them
out which is why I said to
everybody my Clerk's going to check to
printed I'll
said no okay we're trying to see if we
can find your bill in print
uh and I'll repeat again I make or ask
our clerk to send out the agenda and all
the bills attached in one PDF so if you
bring your laptop like some of the
representatives do you should have them
on your laptop if not I kindly ask you
so that we don't have this question
about do we have the copies print them
out that gives you an opportunity to
read them in advance of the hearing too
which isn't a bad idea right so that
would be nice and uh it does take her
time to ass simulate them and put them
together because we never did that in my
prior years on the committee um so I
want to thank uh our committee secretary
for doing that but let let's try to take
advantage of it that would be great and
now I'm getting passed around all the
okay so now I'm going to open the
hearing on HB 595 FN relative to Coastal
resilience zones and she he's already at
the head table this is the prime sponsor
that will be introducing the bills
representative Ms representative thank
you Mr chairman and uh thank you members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Chris muns I'm one of the four
state representatives along with
representative bridel from uh rockium
District 29 representing the town of
Hampton I'm here to introduce HB
595 the title of the bill suggests that
its purpose is to create Coastal
resilience zones that is in fact what I
titled the LSR but as I worked to craft
the language of the bill I realized that
much of what I was suggesting applied as
much to the communities in the White
Mountains Lakes Region and managot
region as it does to Hampton and other
communities on the Sea
Coast the frequency of significant
weather events that result in flooding
and other damage has increased and will
continue to do so changes in our climate
and weather patterns is super charging
the water cycle leading to heavier
rainfall extremes across the country
including in New Hampshire a recent
study from Dartmouth College found that
events that will bring 1 and a half
inches or more of heavy rainfall or
melted snowfall in one day are
anticipated to increase 52% by the end
of the century a report prepared by the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration office for Coastal
management for the Seabrook Hampton's
Estuary Alliance in May
2024 concluded that there is a
67% chance that sea levels will rise
between .3 and 7 ft by 2030 and 0.5 and
1.3 feet by
2050 attached to the copy of my written
testimony are pictures from the flooding
that occurred in Hampton in January
2023 and in the manad region in July of
2023 these weather events not only
resulted in millions of dollars of
Damages but disrupted the lives of
hundreds if not thousands of our fellow
citizens many of whom are constituents
of those of us in this room in the case
of many of Representative Bridal and my
constituents in Hampton it continues to
do so whenever there is an unusually
high tide or strong storm and is not the
large homes that face the ocean that
incur the damage the most damage it is
the smaller summer cottages purchased
years ago and handed down through
generations and that have but the marsh
that are most
affected if sea levels rise by one foot
it will affect approximately 1750 homes
in Seabrook Hampton and Hampton Falls
the estimated assessed value of those
properties is approximately $450
million if 10% of those properties were
lost due to storm damage Not only would
the owners of those properties
properties suffer significant loss but
the rest of us in cra Hampton and
Hampton Falls would have to make up the
approximately
$750,000 annual loss in property taxes
that would result and then there are the
higher insurance rates that many of us
across New Hampshire will have to pay to
offset those Insurance
losses now multiply that by the number
of other towns along the Sea Coast and
along our lakes and rivers who are and
will be experiencing increased
flooding the cost to address this
Challenge and make ourselves more
resilient is enormous and government
cannot be expected to provide all the
necessary funding it will take a public
private partnership and some creative
thinking much of the work that is taking
place in our cities and towns today to
address this real risk is focused on
improving the resilience of our public
infrastructure the focus of HB 595 is to
provide our cities and towns with some
additional Tools in their toolbox
to help individual home and business
owners who are interested and willing to
invest in making their properties more
resilient to flooding the bill has four
components first in sections 1- n
sections 1-9 do a couple of things first
it defines flood resiliency improvements
and adds them to the list of what are
considered qualifying improvements under
50 sa 53f for New Hampshire's commercial
property assessed clean energy cace
program this program makes it possible
for commercial property owners to obtain
lowcost long-term financing from private
lenders for Energy Efficiency water
conservation and renewable energy
projects these upgrades can be financed
with no money down and then repaid as a
uh benefit assessment on the property
tax tax bill over a term that matches
the useful life of the
improvements the assessment transfers on
the sale of the property and can be
passed through to tenants where
appropriate this secondly within
sections 1- n uh it extends a similar
financing option to individual
homeowners known as rpce residential
property assess Clean Energy Florida has
recently done this and specifically
included flood resilience projects as
qualifying improvements
sections 10 through 13 on pages 5 and
six of the bill enables cities and towns
to Grant individual homeowners who
invest in flood resiliency improvements
either an exemption from the assessed
value of their property which would not
exceed the value of the Improvement or
an annual property tax credit of between
$100 and $1,000 for up to 5
years section 14
on pages six and seven enables cities
and towns to apply a apply and collect a
municipal flood resilience fee for
deposit in a flood resilience investment
fund this fund would be structured in
such a way that other sources of public
and private funding could be def could
be deposited into it and so that funding
through grants or below Market loans
could be provided to individuals in
intending to invest in qualifying flood
resilience
improvements uh Mr Marcus Landers will
be testifying in favor of this bill and
will share some thoughts on how such a
fund could help to stimulate private
investment I strongly encourage you to
hear him out section
15 provides funding to the Department of
Business and economic Affairs to
complete a Statewide analysis of the
cost of flood risk and the cost and
benefits of flood risk mitigation
given the impact revealed in the study
completed for seab Brook Hampton and
Hampton Falls it seems prudent and
appropriate that the state assess what
those risks are the goal is that such a
study will help to inform and guide
policy makers in additional actions that
should be taken this bill provides for
an additional appropriation to the Bea
with the understanding that any such
appropriation will be offset by any
available fed ederal or private grants
the department may be able to
identify while I cannot say whether they
support the bill I do want to thank the
commissioners of the Departments of
Revenue Administration and business and
economic Affairs and their staffs for
help in drafting this bill since the
bill was introduced they and other
stakeholders including the New Hampshire
Municipal Association the Sara club and
quite frankly some members of this
committee have offered additional
comments and suggestions
and I thank them as well I encourage the
committee to consider all of their
suggestions I will summarize what they
are now but in my written testimony I
have included specific language for an
amendment I am happy to work with you to
adopt first since the proposed Municipal
flood resilience fee will be collected
as an additional assessment on the
assessed value of all property and
collected along with the general
property tax G recommends referencing
The Collection enforcement Powers towns
and cities have under RSA
80 greenwater greenw green storm water
infrastructure has been proven to
control the flood the flow of storm
water and reduce flooding while
providing a variety of other benefits
including cleaner water reduced erosion
and cleaner air it also often is more
cost effective and longer lasting than
other forms of flood control such as
seaw walls and raising built structures
as such the Sierra Club suggests
amending the definition of flood of a
flood resiliency Improvement to include
improvements of that type and I support
that third is introduced the language
defining the scope of the Statewide
economic studies suggests that it must
include all flood prone properties which
would be timeconsuming and like unlikely
to be completed even with a budget of
$500,000 it also is probably not
necessary given that significant Insight
can be gleaned from representative
samples Bea has proposed some amended
language which I which I agree with that
will reduce the scope to something that
is more manageable and can hopefully
provide meaningful insight to guide
policy makers more
quickly fourth the rpce or residential
PACE program has not been as widely
accepted across the country as the c
commercial PACE program that is due to
some concerns about about consumer
protection or def Andor deceptive
lending
practices these have been addressed in
several States including in Florida with
the passage of SB
770 for our Pace s SP 770 provides for
ability to pay income qualifications
including an income test enforces
disclosure methods to increase
transparency and requires informing
homeowners of the importance of
obtaining two estimates from contractors
for large your home improvements
Additionally the legislation requires a
confirmation of terms phone call that
takes place with the homeowner and
provides that no assessment can exceed
exceed 20% of the home's value among
other consumer
protections the municipal Association
alerted me to a bill
sb4 that has already passed the Senate
and had a hearing in the house science
technology and energy committee
yesterday I understand that the
municipal Association worked very
closely with the New Hampshire business
Finance Authority to craft this bill and
that is it is on a fast track to be
submitted to the house for final
approval and to the governor for her
signature it updates RSA chapter 53f and
among among other things designates the
New Hampshire business Finance Authority
as the administrator of the commercial
cace program there's no reason I can
think of that the rpce program I am
proposing in my bill couldn't also be
introduced by the B by the
BFA I will of course defer to the this
committee on the best course of action
but if sb4 is signed into law and HB 595
is amended were to pass the house I
would certainly be work willing to work
with you and members of the Senate to
further modify the language in the final
bill so that so that it is consistent
with
S4 thank you for your attention and
patience I know I have shared a great
deal with you I am happy to try to
answer any questions you may have now
and would also certainly be willing to
participate in a subcommittee if you
choose to designate one thank you any
representative representative
Darby thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative Ms for taking my question
this bill is uh is pretty comprehensive
uh like you just went through thanks for
that
explanation um
I am um I've mentioned to you offline uh
my concerns about uh our pace and um
like you mentioned uh Florida has passed
passed an additional additional
legislation to um provide consumer
protections regarding our PA so I wonder
if it might be appropriate to bring
everything else forward because it's
build has a lot other than the rpce
changes and then um allow for a
subsequent bill that um def provides uh
comprehensive protections for uh for
residents uh to engage in our Pace
because this is our Pace in this bill is
going to extend it Beyond um uh flood
resiliency to all um energy all the
energy programs that are supported by
cpce
today um I I obviously would like to see
you know our Pace move forward as part
of this just so that we we start to give
uh
homeowners um another another mechanism
to finance any improvements they that
they wish but um I understand what
you're saying um and if um you know the
decision of the committee is to carve
the rpce out for now and move forward
with the rest of the bill then I um I I
don't think I would have any strong
objections to that and be happy to work
on putting together an rpce bill um for
the for next
year anyone
else seeing none thank you for your
testimony speaking in favor
representative
Muse thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is representative David Muse I
represent the city of Portsmouth and the
towns of Newington and Newcastle and uh
if you look at a map uh one of the
things you can see pretty quickly is
that uh I represent a pretty fair chunk
of the New Hampshire Sea Coast so Wards
1 and Wards 5 and Portsmouth basically
have about
95% of the uh the land area the coastal
land area and in Portsmouth uh Newcastle
is an island
uh and Newington uh borders on Great Bay
um this is an this is an area I think of
tremendous concern uh to people in my
community and and all up and down the
Sea Coast a lot of people have
invested uh their time uh their money in
not only in uh in purchasing the
properties properties that they own
along the Sea Coast but I know in
Newcastle there are people uh who have
uh who have gotten approval to do
projects um uh to do things like build
seaw walls uh there are folks who have
raised their houses uh as we're talking
about in this bill um these are things
that are basically happening now and and
I think one of the things that we
realize is that we may be one big storm
away from a lot of people not being able
to afford insurance anymore on their
homes or we might even start to see uh
what's happened in Florida and some
other places where some homes just
simply become become uninsurable because
of where they are um we're also seeing a
fair amount of uncertainty at the
federal level around just how much
Disaster Response Aid is going to
continue to be available in situations
like this so given the lack of
predictability at the federal level the
fact that uh Insurance may not be the
may not offer the kind of protection
that it's offered homeowners in the past
I think one of the things that jumps out
to me about this bill is it lets people
and communities protect
themselves um it's an it's an enablement
Bill what it does is it gives
communities like Portsmouth
Newcastle uh Durham do all of the uh the
communities that board bordered the Sea
Coast Title estuaries and as
representative buns was saying also
flood plone areas and other parts of the
state it gives people the ability to do
something to protect their property uh
and it and it helps them band together
in a way that they might not be able to
do uh without legislation like this so I
would ask you to please strongly uh
consider this legislation to work with
representative Ms I've worked with him
on a bunch of other bills uh in my
committee and and we found he's always
receptive to conversation to changes to
good ideas uh he's a great
representative to work with on something
like this and we need to get something
done in this area um thank you very much
any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you have another
cluder I than you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record I'm state
representative John cluder from Sullivan
County District Six which comprises the
communities of Claremont and Cen and I'm
here today in strong support of House
Bill
595 I am not on a list of a sponsor
which is fine but I after I listened to
representative muns some of his emails
and talking about this I feel I wanted
to jump on to show my support and to
emphasize to this committee that this is
just isn't just a Sea Coast issue is an
issue for a lot of the communities I
represent in the western part of the
state Sullivan County including Cen and
aworth Newport planfield among others
because these communities over the last
few years have been devastated by some
floods caused to uh heavy rains that hit
uh those communities I remember the date
I know July of
2023 was and then I think last year
there were also Heavy R
and especially for communities like Cen
aworth who are only 800 residents you
know their roads were devastated uh
their Pro property was damaged I believe
it really caused a lot of damage which
they they're having to deal with they
had to go try to go through FEMA and
they're having problems with FEMA uh and
I and I feel that we do also need to do
more this is an abling legislation that
would help communities hopefully prevent
tragedies you know from occurring the
floods the damages and I think we got to
do more to prevent damage caused by
extreme weather events We Can't Stop
Those events or totally prevent them but
we got to take some measures I think I
think it's government's duty to try to
uh increase Public Safety and limit
people's property damage and I think
this is great enabling legislation that
would do that and I commend
representative muns for doing this but I
want to say it it's again emphasized
it's not just a Sea Coast issue it's an
issue for communities all across that
including the communities I uh represent
which are over in the western part of
the state and the Vermont border because
we have a lot of rivers okay thank you
any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testim thank you Mr chair members
commit speaking in favor Kate Cook city
is your mic on Kate think so there good
good morning honorable chair and
honorable committee members um first I'd
like to highlight for you the support of
the city of Portsmouth for this bill
which is signed in supporting it um I'm
a city councelor in Portsmouth and I am
here to emphasize that support the city
of Portsmouth estimates that 500
properties in Portsmouth are at risk of
flood in the historic district not only
does this flooding impact those Property
Owners but it also impacts the Integrity
of our downtown historic district which
is a major draw for
tourism we are working to try to support
our property owners who are imp impacted
by regular flooding this bill allows for
localities to better develop resources
to address improvements needed due to
that
flooding in my personal capacity I would
like to highlight the immediate
challenges of many of my neighbors and
the benefits of this bill when it comes
to preparedness our residents are facing
significant challenges with the cost of
property improvements addressing what
has become annual flooding in the winter
with rising ocean levels combined with
strong winter storms from my personal
experience I've witnessed the increasing
number of winter storms in flooding
impacting my immediate neighbors I live
adjacent to Mechanic Street in
Portsmouth one of the areas of
Portsmouth that floods regularly my
neighbors and businesses such as goo's
Chowder on Mechanic Street have had to
regularly replace Mechanicals and
interior fixtures due to flooding this
places considerable Financial strain on
these Property Owners many of whom have
lived and worked in these locations
their entire lives these homes and
businesses are not only part of the
fabric of our community but they are
also part of the early Heritage of the
State of New Hampshire the Wentworth
Gardener home a historic treasur sits on
Mechanic Street I should also mention
that Prescott Park and strawberry Bank
are also regularly impacted by this
flooding that directly harms the
Prescott Park Arts Festival gundo
company players ring theater and the
strawberry Bank Museum these nonprofits
are part of the vibrant cultural
community that drives tourism in our
region House Bill 595 helps Property
Owners address the critical improvements
needed for flooding mitigation and
Recovery I ask you to support House Bill
595 to help Property Owners become
become more resilient in the face of
this growing challenge thank you thank
you any questions for the
speaker representative
NAB thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm on the select
board in stratum so I'm going to ask you
sort of a municipal question since
you're here as a municipal
representative um the piece about the
flood resilience investment funds um we
did this in stratum with the
transportation funds but the way of
applying that is to benefit the town and
and you know large groups in the town
I'm a little concerned about those funds
and how they might just benefit an
individual or a business and I wonder
how you think about you would think
about applying those in your city to
avoid sort of this this is we're going
to give all this money to this one
person to fix up their house or how that
would how that would play out thank you
so much for your question this is not a
discussion we've had yet at the
municipal level in Portsmith um I would
welcome the opportunity for us to have
that discussion which we can't have
concurrently because we don't have this
mechanism in place um currently um the
way we address the only way that we can
address um challenges we have around
infrastructure is through um taxation on
our residents and we do have a lot of
infrastructure challenges due to
flooding and so we're looking at having
to mitigate those in the long term but
we haven't been able to even have a
discussion around how we support um not
only businesses and homeowners um but
how we um deal with kind of these
mechanisms because they don't exist
right now I would I would welcome that
discussion and I would say that I think
municipalities are well positioned to um
make critical decisions that um would
benefit
everyone any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony from the New Hampshire
insurance department DJ beton Court Mr
beton
Court thank thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is DJ beton Court I have the
pleasure of serving as the commissioner
of the New Hampshire insurance
department it's nice to see all of you I
don't get to come to many committees
outside of house Commerce and ways and
means so it's good to see some different
faces I wanted to provide you with a
little bit of background obviously from
an insurance perspective more broadly
speaking I'm not going to tell you that
I'm intimately familiar with every
detail of this particular proposal but
what I can say is that we are certainly
aware of the challenges that your
constituents Granite stators who are
living in the Sea Coast and in other
areas of our state are having with
accessibility and affordability of
homeowners insurance coverage and I will
uh divert for a moment to say that since
this particular proposal is focused on
flood one of the most important public
service announcements that I could give
as commissioner and that is to make it
clear at any time at any opportunity you
have with your constituents to make them
aware that they do not have flood
coverage unless they've purchased a
separate flood insurance policy either
through the commercial Market or through
the federal flood insurance program it
is not covered under your underlying
homeowners
insurance representative cluer spoke
about an incident in the summer of 2023
I remember that incident incredibly well
it was my first week as commissioner
there was a horrible flood uh I've been
in public service in one form or fashion
for over 20 years it was by far the
worst set of conversations that I have
ever had to have with members of the
public because they had just lost their
home in some of uh these instances that
lost everything and they were calling me
to get a better understanding of what
coverage they had under their homeowners
insurance
policy to which my response was you
don't have any and so these people were
looking at the prospect of having to
rebuild their entire lives without
having any coverage or any support from
their insurance carrier so that was
obviously quite difficult and quite
tragic for those individuals so I say
that as a bit of a public service
announcement for all of you but getting
back to the insurance piece as it
pertains to this
proposal we are aware that se Coast
residents and others as I've said are
having a hard time with accessibility
and affordability to coverage couple of
different reasons for that right now the
health the insurance industry as a whole
is working through what we would
classify as a hard Market hard Market is
an insurance term which means that the
insurance companies are more tightly
managing their risk they are putting
forward more stringent underwriting
criteria so they're
narrowing their offerings so when
coverages are at traditional demand
levels or higher but the accessibility
to those coverages is more restricted
you have a basic Supply demand dynamic
takehold in which what is left of that
coverage is obviously now more
expensive why are the insurance carriers
managing their risks more judiciously
number of reasons for that some of which
are well known to the public things like
inflation things like interest rates
things like disruption to Global Supply
chains certainly the supply chains are
better than where they were during the
pandemic and in the immediate aftermath
of the pandemic but they're not back to
pre-pandemic levels yet so those things
are obviously drivers of upward pressure
on premiums but those are things that
are cyclical in some event in some
instances and So eventually those
factors will
Abate things that we're going to have to
contend with on a permanent or more
long-term basis are things that are also
driving this hard market like
catastrophic weather events that are
becoming more severe and more frequent
think the Hurricanes that wipe out
Florida or the Gulf Coast or the
Carolinas think of the horrific fire
that we just saw in Los Angeles uh those
are huge events that result in insurance
carriers having to pay out a lot of
money those are huge losses for those
companies and the fact that we have a
lot of Technology that's coming online
in our cars and in our homes and the
vast majority of that technology is
great because it's all safety oriented
and we want that but it is expensive the
technology itself is expensive the
expertise to install or repair and
replace that technology
requires um an individual who's going to
cost more to do that work to come out
and do that repair work or to install
that particular or reinstall that
particular piece of technology in your
home or car when it breaks so all of
that has come together to uh create a
hard market for consumers and so they're
seeing as I've said increases in
premiums they're seeing
non-renewals and this is particularly
pronounced in those problematic areas in
the Sea Coast and in the other areas
that you've heard referenced today so I
will say that as a broad matter again
I'm not intimately familiar with every
provision of this proposal I suspect
there going to be some areas you'll want
to think about and work over but what I
can tell you is that the spirit of this
program is a good one because it will
better position consumers in the
underwriting process when they are
trying to get homeowners insurance
coverage or get their current homeowners
insurance coverage
renewed that they themselves or their
Community have taken a number of steps
to make that property make that home
more resilient so that God forbid there
should be a flood event the damage to
that home is going to be less it will be
mitigated and so the hope is that
because of that work because of those
improvements as that consumer goes
through the underwriting process with
whomever is quoting them
on their coverage they'll be in a better
place and so they'll get at least the
offer for Renewal with their current
carrier and not kicked into the Surplus
lines Market which is a very expensive
Market to get coverage uh or not only
will they be renewed but they'll have a
lower premium quoted to them than they
had before as a result of this work so
we are as I've said uh in a place where
we look favorably towards proposals like
this the department is actually bringing
forward a separate program that's more
widely applicable but these are the
types of things that I think all of us
need to have a thorough conversation
around in terms of how are we going to
deal with the fact that we cannot
obviously control the weather but the
weather is having a huge impact on our
constituents in a number of different
ways and for the insurance aspect of it
we think programs like this
can be potentially very very helpful so
with that Mr chairman I'll hand it back
over to you any questions for the
speaker a bunch representative Darby
then representative NAB uh thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um we've heard uh in California that
there's a sort of the state provides a
high-risk Market pool for you know for
those areas that um traditional insurers
won't cover anymore plan um does does
New Hampshire have something like that
New Hampshire does not have a fair plan
and I will tell you that I am not a fan
of fair plans for a couple of different
reasons the first
is in California's case the program is
horribly administered they can't
properly process claims the customer
service is terrible I don't know what on
Earth they're going to do as a result of
this horrific wildfire in Los Angeles
California's in a bit of a a bit of a
bad place with their insurance Market at
the present time a lot of different
reasons for that um FAIR Plan the idea
of a fair plan is that when there is no
other insurer that will take you you
have a fallback position it's a insurer
of Last Resort so to speak uh and the
problem is that it doesn't always work
that way um in Massachusetts for example
the fair plan is the preferred option of
people in Massachusetts because they've
Juiced the subsidies in that program
such that it's completely undercut their
commercial market and everybody just
wants to go to the fair plan as a
fundamental matter two things first is I
don't believe that New Hampshire needs
it we have a very competitive
marketplace right now we have over 200
players who are writing coverage for
homeowners in auto insurance in New
Hampshire so there's more than adequate
competition I don't think that we should
take dramatic steps in a difficult
cycle I think we have to see where this
cycle ultimately brings us before we
take dramatic steps that could
permanently
disrupt the competitive industry that we
have at present now obviously if the
current conditions extend out over a
number of years well then it's going to
be time for us to come back together and
start weighing options and thinking
about what other tools we need to bring
to bear to deal with that but I I don't
think that we're there yet and again as
a fundamental matter I get very very
uncomfortable when you are talking about
making government an active player in an
otherwise privatized Market governments
just have advantages that the private
sector does not most glaringly you know
if a an insurance company makes a series
of bad decisions they've got two choices
they can either make adjustments to
right siiz their operation or they can
go out of
business government never goes out of
business we'll just go get more money
and so because of that permanency of the
government being a player in that
Dynamic where the other players are not
they're obviously held to a different
set of factors and standards and
considerations I I think the disruption
to again our otherwise competitive
market um we just would not be benefited
by a fair plan representative na
you're all set any other questions from
Mr beton Court one
more thank you Mr chairman thank you for
the question uh would wind and or fire
uh damage be Nally covered by homeowners
or not uh yes so I always say this
you've got to read your policy to make
sure you know exactly what's in there uh
but typically the standard is if it is
an incident that is sudden and
accidental it should be covered as a as
a broad matter Christian is that right
yeah yep broad broadly speaking U fire
for sure fire for sure and wind yeah
wind would be
covered anything else from Mr baton
Court saying none thank you very much
for your testimony I have one more pink
card in favor Marcus Landers I believe
he passed out some written testimony
also
thank you Mr Landers for speaking if if
you don't mind me saying I would hope
you're not going to read line for line
your written testimony uh if you want to
paraphrase it since everybody has it and
we're running behind in our hearings
appreciate it absolutely I'll shorten it
up a little bit but um Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak today for the
record my name is Marcus Landers I'm a
Marine Corps veteran Harvard Business
School graduate and I've worked as a
general contractor here in the in the
granite state flood proofing homes for a
few years now beyond my work in
construction uh I research and advocate
for flood resilience as a veteran fellow
at uh the Hoover institution and my
mission is to protect America from the
accelerating threat of natural hazards
particularly flood New Hampshire has a
ton of risk right now and according to
the First Street Foundation which is a
leading risk modeling firm floting
threatens right now 60,000 New Hampshire
properties worth tens of billions of
dollars without action over the next
three decades um New Hampshire could
face billions of property damage
storm surge alone threatens a quarter of
the properties in the Sea Coast but this
is a Statewide issue and plal flooding
threatens communities in luconia and all
the way up to the northern most Rees of
the state destruction of value begins
long before the waters rise however
without investments in resilience
Insurance markets will begin to price in
risk driving premiums to unsustainable
levels insurers are now fleeing disaster
prone markets in Florida California and
even in coua New Jersey where I grew up
leaving homeowners without affordable
coverage as insurance becomes scarce the
mortgage Market also tends to dry up the
result is a downward spiry where home
values will plummet because no one can
buy or sell real estate not due to
actual floods but to the due to the
anticipation of one looming devaluation
threatens the broader New Hampshire
economy as Pro declining property values
affect the tax base and the funds
essential to essential services like
schools and law enforcement no one know
exactly when this tipping Point's going
to come but history suggests that
markets correct they do so efficient
efficiency L and swiftly and if the the
crisis fully manifest it will be too
late to prevent the economic collapse in
vulnerable regions and also the broader
State economy that's why this is a
Statewide issue the danger is clear on
paper and there there are reason and if
you look at an Excel spreadsheet it
seems why wouldn't people invest there
are a couple of things and moral
hazardous elements of the market that
are creating bad incentives first is
that insurance for flood insurance is
subsidized and that's creating broken
pricing signals both for th those
Insurance markets and for home
prices homeowners have a false sense of
security uh because their their
insurance is naturalized like we
mentioned before about a fa plan this is
offered through FEMA and the Legacy
rates don't reflect risk second home
owners expect the government to come in
and provide disaster relief creating
perverse incentive not to act before the
storm if you talk to homeowners in
Florida after mil Milton and Hela you
would they would discount this
expectation as Federal coffers are
stretched thinner and thinner by more
disasters lastly resilience retrofits
are often cost prohibitive I've worked
as a structural lifting contractor in
this state it it hovers between $150 and
$200,000 to drisk your home for that
specific retrofit banks are not lending
because the there's not a a resultant
value add to the home value because of
these perverse incentives and in a
higher interest rate environment like we
currently have seeking outside capital
is particularly
expensive the National Institute of
building Sciences has proven that every
dollar spent on flood frud protection
saves taxpayers $7 in post post flood
recovery HB 595 can Pioneer the methods
to increase homeowners the homeowners
and private sector's share of each
dollar invested such they can
appropriately capture their share of the
$7 saved so expanding cpce and rpce
funding creates more viable financing
options that are cheaper for the
homeowner offering tax incentives can
correct the bad incentives that we spoke
to before creating flood resilience
zones can can empower the community to
act on their own accord and this study
will prove that this is an investment
and not just fiscal wanting fiscal
spending that there is some value Val
add to doing this this bill embodies the
New Hampshire's tradition of local
control and fiscal responsibility and it
does not mandate heavy-handed government
intervention but provides a nudge for
the for the private Market to correct to
correct itself and and catalyze private
investment FEA which in my experience is
staed by faint patriotic and diligent
people does not have the resources the
bandwidth to save New Hampshire Federal
flood mitigation funds are already
highly competitive and the Trump
Administration has in has implicated
that they want states to take more
responsibility for the Emergency
Management and preparedness and while
New Hampshire's new Emergency Management
emergency and flood plane managers are
exceptionally capable and diligent
people they cannot mobilize or or raise
the capital necessary to solve this
issue on their own this is where the
free market capitalized this bill must
step into this void in the
void in a perfect world this bird Bill
provides incentive Corrections creating
foundation for an expanded public
private partnership and the non-aps
investment resilience investment fund
will play a crucial role acting as seed
Capital to demonstrate the the viability
of flood resilience
financing H HB 595 is not spending it is
about investing in New Hampshire to
present for the present and the future
and creating the conditions for the
private sector to act if you pass this
bill we will take the first step in
proving that smart policy can correct
broken incentives and make New Hampshire
a leader in resilience and Market driven
climate adaptation thank you for your
time and happy to answer any questions
any questions from Mr
Landers representative
NAB thank you Mr chair I would just um I
don't think we actually all got copies
of your testimony and I wonder if you
could email it to the committee later
absolutely that' be great thank
you how many copies did you bring with
you Mr L I only brought four sir I
apologize it's probably why me and the
one yeah if you could send it in that
way everybody can get it that'd be great
Landers don't see any thank you very
much for your testimony is there anyone
else to
speak on HB 595 FM relative to Coastal
resilience zones don't see anybody
approaching uh blue sheets and online uh
representative
Sergeant yeah online we have 12 in favor
four opposed and the blue sheet is one
in favor one
opposed thank you appreciate that and I
know we're running late but I want to
get this last hearing before we break
and then we'll come back at 1 um I open
the hearing on HB 607 FN relative to
funding the Hampton Beach area
therefore I'm just getting cards so is
the prime sponsor here yes would you
like to uh take the stand and testify
thank you representative muns thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
I promise not to take up nearly as much
as of your time as I did earlier um for
the record once again my name is still
Chris Ms and I still am a representative
from Rockingham District 29 which covers
the entire town of Hampton the Hampton
Beach area commission was established in
2003 by the New Hampshire
hbac the hbac is an oversight commission
that helps the town of Hampton and the
state of New Hampshire with long-term
planning for the Hampton Beach area it
is made up of members from the town
State Hampton Beach Village district and
the Hampton Area Chamber of Commerce the
commission is currently chaired by
former state representative Tracy
Emerich who served in this legislature
for 12 years and the vice chair is The
Honorable Pat bushway who served in the
house for two years the commission's
work includes implementing the Hampton
Beach master plan to do that RSA 216 j3
says that it should assist the town the
state and town in acquiring lands and
rights in plans to ensure a consistent
management of the plan assist the town
to develop building and Zoning code
language and design review guidelines
and procedures for the plan area provide
advice and counsel to the state and town
on proposed land use developments and
capital projects for consistency with
the plan consult with the Hampton Beach
area businesses and residents to promote
the plan meet at least quarterly with a
quorum of at least five members and meet
at least annually with the Selectmen and
prein Precinct Commissioners and provide
a written report annually honor before
November
1st however since its Inception the
commission has not been allocated any
funding to do any of
that this bill would provide the
commission with a small sum of
$5,000 in each of the next two years to
enable it to carry out its duties I urge
you to recommend this bill as ought to
pass and I would be happy to try to
answer any question questions you may
have but I also know that there are uh
several members from the commission here
who are planning to testify any
questions for the
representative representative NAB thank
you Mr chair just a quick question have
there been previous efforts to get
funding for the
commission um I'm not sure but I know
that there has never been any funding
okay representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
does um does Hampton Beach does the town
of Hampton provide any funding for the
commission uh no the h no the town does
not this is a state agency it's not a a
town
agency any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative for your
testimony I have two cards here they're
names of these represent uh
representatives of the Hampton Beach
area commission were named I don't know
if you both want to come up at the same
time and take turns and then we could
ask because you're both on the same
Commission
there's three of you well I can't put
three of you on the
table so I have Tracy amerck first and I
her Center of
ahead look for the red light okay thank
you
morning um jman harb and committee
members for the record I am Nancy Styles
uh formerly chair of the Hampton Beach
area commission for the past six years
um just turned that all over to um
Tracy couple of weeks
ago
um first of all uh representative Ms has
giv you more or less the background and
the history of the hbac I would just
like to add that uh in that require in
the requirement from the state is is to
update the master plan every 10 years um
in the past few years we have begun that
process and in uh 2016 we completed the
transportation component of the master
plan and most recently uh we've
completed the environmental and Coastal
resilience uh portions of the uh master
plan and turned that in as well and
after turning in each of the components
we take them to the Hampton planning
board and get them adopted within the
Hampton uh master plan as well so it's
itself excuse me um basically the uh
hbac holds um eight to nine meetings a
year and sometimes additional sub
commmittee meetings as as well there are
nine members of the commission uh
identified by this uh the legislature
must serve on that
commission and over the past few years
we have had small fundraisers to raise
some money to pay for uh someone to take
the minutes of the meeting because um
Lifestyles have changed since 20 2003
and people who serve on committees don't
always have extra time to do extra
duties so we found it most important to
have someone specifically dedicated to
taking the
minutes and since the commission was um
organized in um 2003 we have taken the
minutes the agendas and the minutes and
the documents from 2003 to
2016 and put them into a bound copies
that that are stored in the town uh
Library there so that people can go to
look at them for re uh research or easy
accessibility and we're currently in the
process of taking the minutes uh uh and
uh up through 2024 and having some more
bound copies made so that anyone looking
at what has been going on uh in the
commission can can find that
easily there's still one more uh section
of um master plan to be updated and that
is the business and economic uh uh
component of the of the plan and that
will start as soon as we can find a
grant to help cover those costs because
what we have done in the past is always
seek grants to bring in Professionals in
the area to uh make sure our master plan
is current and effective and easy enough
to
follow uh the uh commission has also
been active in the um most recent uh
repair to the uh well actually
replacement of the Hampton river bridge
and we have been very active uh as the
state moves forward to reconstruct route
1A uh specifically for flooding issues
that's a big concern of many of the
people that live uh in in that area and
as we know uh uh grants are great but
you can't really find a grant for
operating costs and so um on my exit
from the Hampton Beach area commission
uh we have been asked um to seek other
alternatives to help support that and an
analysis of those costs has been about
$5,000 a year and I'm thankful to the
representatives for putting that bill
forward um and hopefully that you will
accept that and uh we can continue our
our work because the commission does do
a lot of work they are really an advise
and consent to both the state and the
town on issues that affect the uh
Beach any questions for the
senator seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have one copy and I'm
fortunately my printer wasn't working
well if you can give the copy to the
clerk and maybe you could email it in to
the committee then everybody will get a
copy okay I we do that thank you
clean so is that Pat
Pat bushway also from the Hampton Beach
area
commission thank you Mr chair member of
members of the committee uh in addition
to what has already been uh presented to
you by uh representative muns and
Senator Styles um I I would just like to
add that the the Hampton Beach area
commission is a very well-respected
organization uh in our area for the work
that is done
and and it has proven to be a key player
in expanding the Vitality vibrancy and
resiliency of Hampton Beach as well as
the adjacent Coastal communities and and
and the resources to continue that
important work uh that we that is
ongoing as especially Senator Styles
laid out is really important to us so
that we can uh continue to work with the
town of Hampton and the all the the
coastal communities um to make sure that
we uh continue to to preserve the the
the community that we have there thank
you well thank you very much any
questions seeing none thank you for your
amerck Hampton Beach thank you Mr chair
my name is Tracy emri I am the newly
mted chair of the Hampton Beach area
commission I've attended two me meetings
and I'm not so I'm not all uh
knowledgeable about everything it does
but I do know that we don't have any
funds to
communicate in Hampton we have a as
other communities do that have
Recreation we have a Confluence of state
and local jurisdictions that overlap so
the Hampton area Beach commission has
acted as a lubricant if you will to make
everybody happy and to have the various
egos get along with each other that's my
observation in talking to past members
of the of this commission uh one of the
things I identified early on is we we
have a meeting every month that is
televised in the on the local channel
but beyond that we don't have any funds
to update our website the current
website was developed in 2006 and other
than changing participants on the
committee it has not been updated since
then so it and today in today's world
most people look to the web as as
information resource so that's why we
requested representative Ms to put in
this bill so we'd have at least enough
funds to update the website about what's
going on because there's a lot going on
one of the most interesting uh issues
right now is the fact that the uh
Department of Transportation is redoing
Ocean Boulevard which is 1A and there's
a there's a an issue about the sidewalk
who owns a sidewalk so that's unresolved
right now uh but that's part of our is
to get in the middle of that and help
that move forward that's kind of I'm
looking at that as a very immediate plan
because that after 15 years uh Ocean
Boulevard is going to is scheduled for
its final hearing next summer to be
upgraded so that being said I would
appreciate you uh having a positive vote
for 607 uh so that we might be able to
communicate with our community I'll be
glad to answer any
questions representative
donelly thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so I uh I do lots of
volunteer work when it comes to updating
websites and doing that for free um have
you looked at any free website
applications like such as Google sites
and other things where you don't need to
incur such
costs I haven't I don't know that much
about that so I couldn't really respond
I know we have a subcontractor that is
the programmer that did the site in 2006
is willing to continue but she's not
free
unfortunately any other
questions sing none thank you for your
testimony I don't have any other pink
cards on HB 607 FM maybe we could go to
the blue sheets and online uh
representative
Sergeant there are online four in favor
three opposed blue
sheet one in favor thank thank you so
seeing no one approaching the speaker
table uh I declare HB 607 FN hearing
closed remind you we come back at 1:00
so uh you're free to go to 1:00 thank
much
e
I'm going to call the hearing on HB 624
FNA establishing a local River
Management advis committee grant program
and making an Appropriations therefore
to order I'm going to call on the prime
sponsor representative Eric turer he's
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you members of the committee um I'm here
to offer House Bill
624 a bill to establish what I'll
characterize as a modest Grant Pro
program under the department Department
of Environmental Services uh to support
the activities of the legislatively
established but voluntarily run local
River advisory committees throughout the
state the River Management and
protection program was established in
1989 um through RSA 483 to protect
certain New Hampshire Rivers nominated
by their communities as designated
rivers of which there are 19 in the
state the program consists of a two-tier
advisory committee approach including
the Statewide New Hampshire River
Management advisory committee rmac and
the local River Management advisory
committees
lac's this bill focuses on provided need
providing needed
resources for the local advisory
committees which rely on the volunteer
efforts of approximately 200 volunteers
Statewide I've personally been a
volunteer member of the local advisory
committee for the exitor squamscott
river for over 10 years and can attest
to the value and level of the diverse
expertise and knowledge that this
committee brings to the oversight of our
River and this can be extrapolated
across the state the impetus for this
idea was raised in one of our committee
meetings as we reviewed our very limited
Financial Resources in comparison to our
duties as an Lac the duties of these
legislatively established committees are
set forth in RSA 483 colon
8-a in short they involve establishing a
river management plan which can take on
many
dimensions but always involves a
detailed review of and comment on all
proposed changes taking place within the
river Corridor our comments while
advisory are generally welcomed and
incorporated into the proposed projects
lac's also conduct a wide range of
educational monitoring and community
activities for the betterment of our
Rivers uh in terms of why the fundings
needed so when the when the LA's were
first established they could access
funds which primarily came from the
epa's 60 sorry
604b uh grant program um what's happened
since then is those funds have become
much harder to obtain and they've really
been prioritized to other purposes so
they're largely not available for that
function anymore uh this is greatly
impacted degree to which the lac's can
fulfill their
legislatively uh established Mission um
in terms of what these funds might
support um a a brief list of things that
that uh lac's conduct um uh there's a
good deal of administrative support that
is needed um my committee has a a a
person that we hire from our uh
Rockingham Planning Commission um for
$2,000 doll that she does many times
that in her work um we also sometimes
need technical consultants and support
um we need often to have space for
public meetings can which can involve
cost um there's River monitoring
equipment for committees that that
involve themselves directly in that
process um there's often data collection
and Analysis cost um there's
considerable development of educational
materials and websites uh there's a lot
of community engagement so events
regarding the river and informing people
and connecting people with the rivers um
and also you know upkeeping maps and
signage so that people are aware of you
know where the rivers are and how to
access them that's a that's a short list
of what might be covered by um these
funds
um I'll I'll I'll say you might see in
the B the bill that it's requesting
$40,000 each year and then it puts a cap
of10 ,000 per award I want to make it
clear the likely goal or the intended
goal is not to fund four organizations
at that level um we wanted to allow
projects up to uh $10,000 which puts it
below governor and Council threshold um
but uh the expectation is many of the
Committees would request far less and so
the funds would would go to many more uh
lac's across across the state um I
understand and it's a tight budget year
um so I know this is the policy uh
review of of the um proposal it will
then go on to to to uh financial review
um I do want to point out uh as you'll
see it's only authorized for the for two
years um during that time we hope to see
how uh These funds are utilized by the
lacc's and um you know if those uh
resources look to be beneficial we we
would hope to it would continue but
that's not in the in the current
proposal um with that I'll end my
testimony and take any questions anyone
have any questions for the
representative representative NAB thank
you Mr chair thank you for being here
and taking my question um I don't know
if you saw but Dees expressed concerns
about the rul making piece of this um
for such a small amount that it might be
sort of a large amount of time to do
that and made a suggestion in changing
their language I don't know if you saw
that or if you have any cons if you
would I'm let the folks uh from Dees
speak to that um but you don't have any
concerns about the idea of just of
changing that language so it doesn't
involve Ru making and no the idea of
this is not to be burdensome to anyone
so if it can be accomplished more
effectively that way then then that's
certainly okay with me okay thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair and since
the question came up about the dees I'm
going to call call up Tracy sales from
the dees and remind you that uh
commissioner Scott did pass out written
testimony you should have it just to
sales on okay there we go so uh thank
you chair harb and members of the
committee for uh hearing me today uh my
name is Tracy sales I am the rivers and
lakes programs administrator at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services in that role I administer and
manage the rivers management and
Protection Program um I have been with
the program for almost 13 years now um
and uh really appreciate that uh Eric
has um
has got the the lac's best interest in
mind
so um nhds takes no position on House
Bill 624 so I'm here just to provide
information and answer questions um I
will note as um has already been stated
there is a proposed amendment on page
two of the testimony that we've handed
out that is Administrative in nature and
we are happy to take suggestions on how
to um best distribute funds should they
move
forward uh some background about the
program um as representative tur
mentioned uh the bill provides funding
to our local River Management advisory
committees their volunteer groups
authorized under RSA 483 the Rivers's
management and Protection Program when a
river is
designated um all 19 designated rivers
are a result of a Grassroots effort by
their local communities and it requires
both legislative and Governor approval
uh through the bill process the purpose
of the program is to coordinate the many
uses of our rivers and promote
communication both between
municipalities and between
municipalities in the
state as mentioned the local advisory
committees are made up of volunteer
members representing their
municipalities along the rivers and
they're a key component of the rivers
management Protection Program um and
have four statut
duties those Duties are one to advise uh
Dees the Statewide Rivers management
advisory committee and the riverfront
municipalities on issues relating to
management of the river to comment on
federal state and local permits and
plans for projects which may impact
their Rivers develop and implement the
corridor management plan and promote its
adoption among on um in local Master
plans and report to Dees the rivers
management advisory committee and
municipalities on Regulatory Compliance
and the activities of the Lac on behalf
of the
river examples of lac's of activities
that lac's undertake in the
implementation of their duties include
Outreach of community events youth
education water quality monitoring River
cleanups work with communities on issues
of flooding runoff and erosion and they
act as a conduit for community members
the dees expects as representative turer
mentioned that these funds would be used
to help the lacc's meet their statutory
duties uh holding meetings um printing
flyers and creating displays for
outreach events writing and updating
their Corridor plans including GIS maps
and Analysis that require hiring a
contractor implementing those plans
including water quality monitoring
supplies and testing beyond what is
available through the dees volunteer
River Assessment program um and hosting
websites for posting meeting notices and
Min under RSA
481a as well as information about the
river and the lac's
activities uh with respect to the
proposed amendment again this is an
administrative Amendment and the idea
was simply to make the process of
dispersing the funds as easy and simple
as possible for such a small amount of
money um we are welcome to uh any
suggestions on how to best accomplish
this and if rules are the best way to do
that we're happy to do that
too if you have any questions beyond
that I am happy to answer them thank you
any questions for the speaker
representative donelly thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um how much do you give for Grants to
we do not uh this program does not give
money to New Hampshire Lakes other
programs at Dees have for specific
projects such as
cyanobacteria okay thank you other
speaker I don't see any hands raised so
uh thank you very much for your
presentation thank you very much
chairman speaking in support of the
bill Michelle Trembley from New
Hampshire Rivers
Council
Michelle what's
this okay is everyone able to hear
me I I was past the note and it's not
for you but for everyone if you're
speaking remember the little light has
to be on so it'll say red it'll look red
so you could see it and if you can push
the the mic closer to you not only for
us in the room but also for the tape and
the live streaming it would be helpful
thank you to all of our speakers thank
you great I love it when people pass
notes it's it it gives these uh
proceedings a great deal of intrigue so
thank you for sharing that one my name
is Michelle Trembley and I'll offer
testimony for two organizations that I
lead the first is the New Hampshire
Rivers Council and you have that letter
in front of you with the blue logo up at
at the top I won't read it and I won't
go over any ground covered but I do want
to uh say that the New Hampshire Rivers
Council has been there since the start
for those of you who have ever wondered
what that poster is right there with the
five bands of river pictures our R&D is
near and dear to our hearts because it
originally passed RSA 483 with those
five rivers in the beginning and since
then 22 rivers or river segments are in
the program and 20 local River
Management advisory committees are
active this comprises about uh over a
th% uh Pardon Me a th000 River miles
that's about N Out of our
19,000 miles of rivers that's about 50%
of the states municipalities or
localities that are in the program with
about 200
volunteers the value so far that they've
donated as of the last banum report is
about
$157,000 so the state does see a great
return on its investment and this very
modest grant program will add very
little to the budget hardly noticeable
as far as Appropriations are concerned
but it will return a great deal and in
addition to sponsors kraton and
representatives turo I am also part of
an Lac I've been chair for almost all of
of its Charter 35 years so more than
half of my life has been spent on one
and everyone who has served on them I
believe feels very strongly that this is
a great service to municipalities they
are nominated by select boards City
council's Boards of Alderman and then
they're appointed by the rivers
management advisory committee so this is
a groundup effort and it's really
important to note that they work closely
representing their municipalities in
particular the management plans which is
one of the two statutory duties this is
more or less an unfunded mandate because
the river advisory committees do not
have a dedicated funding source so I
want to thank Representatives Crayton
and tur for bringing this bill forward
and I um that will conclude that
testimony until you ask me to speak for
the rivers management advisory
committee so on her one hat anybody have
a question for
her I don't see any but why don't you
just stay there and tell us about your
second hat I appreciate second and by
the way I'm not sick I'm in an immune
compromis household but this is what I
look like when I'm working in my office
all right on to the next volunteer
activity and that is the rivers
management advisory committee which I
chair again will not read the letter but
I wanted to accentuate that this program
has these multiple levels the state
level and the local level and the
rmac rivers management advisory
committee feels very strongly that the
cities and towns are ultimately going to
benefit from the volunteers work if they
have a little boost with their funding
and without funding we have the
$157,000 in match the belief is is that
you'll see manyfold a return if this
modest appropriation is passed and and
um the the statutory requirement has
been of significant concern for some
time because many lac's want to fulfill
this obligation but have not been able
to because there really is a requirement
to have some Technical Resources and
some staff people available to just
boost those volunteer efforts and get
them over the finish line so that
municipalities can have these plans so
both the RAC and the New Hampshire
Rivers Council feel strongly that this
is a great use of State resources we
both recognize that this is a
challenging time and we understand that
you've been given guidance but we
believe that there are ways that this
modest amount of funding each year can
be placed in the budget thank you any
trambley thank you very much appreciate
testimony I have one more p card excuse
bill did I say your name right for the
record said it right thank
you Mr
birdie there we go thank
you uh M chairman and committee members
appreciate the opportunity
to speak today I speaking I'm going to
have a dual role here one I submitted
for the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association for Jason stock who is the
director uh he had a conflict so I am I
was I am a past president of the
Timberland Owners
Association and currently excuse me
currently serve on the policy board um
the letter is I together and the
testimony is
self-explanatory and U so Mr if I can
interrupt you yeah I was giving you a
card for um 624 but you're on
629 you're on the dam Bill the dam is we
can say that Amo early it's the damn
bill no I called you up because they put
you too early okay oh you may be next
but you're a little too early for this
bill
you know Miss Trembley wanted to hear
all about the dams and how it affects
the
rivers hang around cuz Mr Birdie's
coming back okay thank that's all right
I was directed to just no I called you
up because you were in the
stack so I don't have any other cards
for 624 is there anyone else that wants
to speak on House Bill 624 anyone else
House Bill
624 so now our sergeant-at-arms
representative
is going to give us the low down on the
internet thank you Mr chair blue sheets
we have 18 in support online three
opposed uh four in support on the blue
sheet and one opposed uh and one neutral
thank you very much so I'm going to
close the hearing on HB 624
FNA
and we have to wait 3 minutes Mr birdie
to call you up so if if anyone else has
a card on 629 we'll be happy to take it
you can pass it Forward on 629 we will
put them in your
629 that was the lunch time batch she's
trying to help me out over here
represent you know we're we're a team
alone why they put these
no
so while we're waiting for 1:30 to come
I just want to remind all the
representatives again before next
Wednesday your respective parties will
have their caucuses Wednesday morning
we're exacting the eight bills we're
hearing today Wednesday afternoon we'll
exact the four bills that we'll hear
after we exec the eight bills in the
morning and as of today that will bring
us up to speed and date uh for our bills
and we'll see if any more come in in the
next week or
so thank you and I want to if I didn't
say it before I want to thank everybody
for getting their reports in that helps
me uh I think the process that we did
the first 10 bills work out excellent uh
if we could just keep that up because
we've got the eight and then the three
uh so we got another 11 to to write U
but we'll have time and we'll still
still follow that same process if I can
get them by the weekend then I have the
weekend to enjoy reading and and working
on them while I'm running around doing
things
e
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
my name is Peter Lehman I represent
Peterboro and Sharon
before I start I would like to thank a
couple of people that were heavily
involved in a committee to study
alternatives to the funding and
operation maintenance and repair of
State own dams one being one of your
members representative dun good to see
you um representative
U wette who may be appearing today to
testify and also Lou delis Sandro
Senator sen delis Sandro was the uh
chairman of this
committee we met five times last year to
discuss some of the ongoing problems
with the state's
dams Mr chairman the state of New
Hampshire finds itself uniquely situated
infrastructure there is not another
state the union that possesses direct
ownership over a significant amount of
dams and impoundments as New Hampshire
does today the State of New Hampshire
owns 276 dams 208 that are directly
operated by the Department of
Environmental Services and any
impoundment exceeding 6
feet is considered in this
figure meanwhile the state of ront
directly owns only 14
dams of the dams not operated by
Dees the remainder are operated among
various agents agencies such as the
University of New
Hampshire their lease to hydro
generators and in recent years the
number of leases to
hydrogenerators has declined presumably
because of the burden of capital
expenditures to maintain these
structures in the event the Lei walks
responsibilities Dees categorizes its
portfolio according to the hazard HDM
poses
Downstream High Hazard dams propose
threat to life significant Hazard dams
pose a threat to the value of
infrastructure and low Hazard dams pose
a threat to minor property loss and non-
menacing dams are which go largely un
noticed when they
breach of the state's 276 dams 64 are
considered high
Hazard 34 are considered significant
Hazard and 80 are lwh Hazard and there
are n 98 non- menacing
structures according to Dees the
approximate cost to rehabilitate and
remediate the aforementioned total would
exceed 400
million Dees provides the dam Bureau
with an annual revenue of roughly $7
million on average evenly split among
the general fund Capital Appropriations
in addition to hydrop power revenues
rental proceeds and other
fees to abide by a 50-year
rehabilitation schedule the dam Bureau
requires $16 million annually current
reeven revenues receive place a dam
Bureau short by over $16 million
annually
and this is only to repair the dams in a
50-year period if we go with it
shortfall it would take over 100 years
to meet our
obligations considering the age and
condition and growth and development
Downstream from State dams it is an
untenable
situation the state began assuming
ownership of dams in the 1940s 50s and
60s many of these new newly acquired
assets were from the 19th and 20th
Century they're Antiquated and have
significantly aging
Parts while the state of New Hampshire
is an exception in respect to the
ownership of its dams it may not be an
exception regarding the growth of the
national Trend in Dam
failures failures have occurred in Texas
Michigan Minnesota Vermont and even in
New Hampshire itself and I do have a
handout Mr the chairman that actually
identifies those dams that have failed
in the uh State recently you may recall
Dam failures in Littleton Forest Lake
Newport and the town of Warren have all
experienced a failure of significant
damage in recent history New Hampshire
Dees asserts that weather and climate
may not be the primary instigator of
these
failures in addition to Rehabilitation
the committee also considered removal of
State
dams regardless of the
removal uh failure of these dams would
actually bring water levels anywhere
between 5 and 10 ft or entirely below
itself in light of the Nationwide
incidences and in light of current
storms and the imminent Revenue
challenges the committee found it
prudent that a stable consistent
mechanism to furnish the Department of
Environmental Services with sufficient
funds for the operation maintenance and
established the current Arrangement is
not
sustainable nor is it in the best
interest of local communities
recreational environmental interests or
future budgets and with that Mr chairman
I'd be happy to take any questions and
with your approval I do have a handout
with which has a lot of information
which I'm sure you'll find interesting
thank you before you hand that out does
representative representative Sergeant
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Mr representative how
did you uh or what's the policy behind
limiting the tax increase to Waterfront
owners well we looked at a number of
options uh one was to fund it through
General funds there was General
consensus wasn't fear to would tax
everybody in the state for something
they may not utilize we looked at the
real estate transfer taxes another
possibility but again people would be
paying that assessment when they would
have no benefit of the DM so we looked
at it at the end when we were done and
we held five public hearings on this
that if someone's directly impacted they
probably should pay the fee and not
someone that wasn't directly impacted so
that's where the fee structure idea came
from representative NAB thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
was there any consideration of um
treating shorel that's not in current
use or that's in conservation
differently than that they they would be
exempt so it would be like commercial
residential but any conservation land
would be exempt from the tax or fee it's
a fee not a tax okay sorry Fe um and UND
undeveloped land would be the same uh if
it was incurrent use yes but if it was
just sitting there would still be
subject to thank you anyone
else representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question um the for some of these dams
as I understand are um impounding
property in impounding water bodies that
do not have Public Access so should um
the all this uh should this load be
spread to all public to all Waterfront
uh property owners in those cases when
uh those water bodies have a very small
um uh number of people that can access
the
water it would be based on any
waterfront property that was actually
created by an impoundment and some of
the information I have here in front of
me just to give you an idea I think most
of you are probably familiar with
Newfound Lake uh in Bristol that's a uh
High Hazard Dam there it's in poor
condition and the height the water
height is 12 feet so if that DM had to
be breached or in other words they not
might necessarily not have to be
breached but the gates would be open the
drain the lake so you could see there'd
be a significant loss of lakefront if
that Dam had to be breached if it you
know you couldn't afford to repair it
and there are other major dams across
the state uh that come to mind uh Lake
wiip uh that impounds 10 fet of
water and that dam is also in poor
condition fair to poor condition and
there's some others that are significant
trouble and uh for instance Lake Sunapee
and that's 14 feet of elevation that the
dam provides so this is a serious
problem and as you can see we've got
hundreds of dams in the state and
without adequate fees to take care of
those dams at some point there will be a
major breach and uh property and lives
lost yes representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question for commercial
use of the dam such as the power
companies how are the fees set with them
they and the dees is behind me they're
probably more familiar with the fee
structure but they all are assessed a
fee if it's a state Dam so they do pay
the state for the use and production of
power at that facility I don't know what
the fees are what they're based on but
they are assessed a fee if it's a
state-owned
dam
sure any other
questions seeing no hands thank you for
your testimony yeah thanks for your
courtesy and if it's all right I pass
those out now while you're passing those
out Corey Clark from New Hampshire dees
are you speaking
I could Mr CH I put in a card for both
of us so I didn't know if you were going
to just watch and see how we did
so actually it's quite the other way
around I
think so for the record I'm Bob Scott
I'm commissioner with the Department of
Environmental Services and Corey and for
the record I'm Corey Clark chief
engineer at the dam Bureau at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services thank you welcome to resources
thank you so the handout we have is that
already gone okay so we have a handout
that's going around uh I don't want to
re reiterate too much of what the the
the uh representative leechman said but
I do want to make some some points uh so
again uh Corey is is our drio chief uh
with a lot of experience uh he replaced
a longtime state employee uh you know
similarly uh as with any change we we we
we tend to relook at things when
somebody new comes in one of the
concerns big largest concerns we had as
articulated is again we we are
responsible for maintenance and
Rehabilitation of the 276 State dams uh
and 64 of those are high Hazard again so
what that means is uh there's potential
loss of Li and property if if the dam uh
were at risk um
so going back in time if we look
historically we are generally funded out
of the capital budget for the repair
shes to state owned dams uh going back
in that same time frame the past decades
the this is not a knock on the the the
general court but the the level of
funding we've been receiving puts us on
a 100-year cycle to
rehabilitate the the 276 dams and that's
that's very was very concerning for me
because of that we asked Last by anym we
asked for the study commission which the
sponsor was was discussing
uh to look for ways for a sustainable
funding source for the dams
so a couple more points uh is so the
high Hazard dams you and I I'll be very
blunt here again that's that involves a
potential loss of life for property uh
the agency certainly not under my watch
you we will not knowingly allow that
type of thing to happen so what that
means as articulated by the sponsor is
if a dam is in a condition where it it
that possible we will be forced to
unilaterally lower the level of that Dam
to make it safe and again as an example
the Lakeport Dam on Lake onab basaki we
would be lowering it 10 feet as an
example uh and there's many examples
throughout the state so that's just a
reality so this is not a case
where if if things aren't funded it's
okay this the dam deteriorates whether
you fund it or not for for the you know
I'm stating the obvious I know so Our
intention was with that study committee
was again to raise awareness I I I truly
believe the average citizen doesn't
really think about the dam that's
holding up the the empowerment uh I'm
here to tell you there's unless you're
using a canoe or a kayak I guarantee you
that water body you're putting your boat
in for example is supported by a dam
that's just the reality in this state um
so that's that's really our goal is to
educate and ultimately find a
sustainable way to fun fund these dams I
I want to thank again representative dun
and and you know the members of the the
committee uh that looked at this uh
we we uh I do have again uh our chief
engineer here we want to make ourselves
available to answer any questions again
it's imperative my view that we find a
sustainable funding source I will say
the actual mechanism of how the funding
happens we're agnostic at this point we
just want to make sure that ultimately
we get to a point where we can find a
sustainable way to fund these dams and
make sure again uh New Hampshire's
economy and and and uh people are are
safe and
commissioner did you want to speak or
you
allet I can speak just real quickly just
kind of bit on the background of the um
Dam maintenance fund question came up
about the hydros how how has that worked
so really um as the sponsor had said
begin beginning around 1937 that's when
the state of New Hampshire started
taking on ownership of some of these
dams and really kind of peaked in the uh
60s and early 70s in which the state
years on years on end were taking over
these dams that originally built in the
1800s by power companies or uh mill
companies and the state was taking over
these assets because they were no longer
uh useful to those companies or the
companies could no longer sustain the
maintenance and the repair costs so the
state was taking that on in the 1980s
the dam maintenance fund was created as
a funding mechanism to support uh the
repair and reconstruction and the
operation of state-owned dams the the
idea behind that is the state of New
Hampshire would lease uh various sites
to hydropower producers and as part of
the revenue they would actually um
receive that as income that would help
support the program um what happened was
is throughout the 1990s the program was
pretty much self-funding uh and then
when the
power power purchase agreements were all
restructured as part of the divestment
that occurred in the
2002 those power purchase agreements
dropped from anywhere from around 15 or
17 cents a kilowatt hour that the Hydro
power producer was getting down to
around 3 cents a kilowatt hour and it's
been like that ever since so since the
early 2000s the uh Revenue coming into
the dam IND this fund has dropped
significantly and also the number of
hydro sites has also dropped in 2004 we
had 12 sites that were we were leasing
for Hydro power that number is now down
to eight so the most recent site that we
just lost that used to create Hydro
power was that Kelly's Falls Dam in
Manchester some of you may have been
familiar with some of the um articles
written on that but essentially that
site was a site in which the hydrop
power producer um was there they were
relicensing that project through the FK
which oversees all hydrop power as part
of the relicensing they were required to
put in fish passage it became
um economically uh unfeasible in order
to actually do that and still make
Revenue at that site so they they
relinquish their lease at that site left
the site and now the dees is now
operating that site without hydr power
so we have a Hydro power unit that's
sitting their idle trying to figure out
what we can do to get that site running
so that's just a bit of the background
of where we're at roughly we get around
$600,000 in revenue from all of our
leases um you know we we discussed uh
lak Port Dam y ois hocki that's a very
small hydropower site that site we get
just around a little over $7,000 in
lease revenue from that site annually so
it certainly helps every little bit does
but it's not going to help on the repair
of the 70-year-old Gates that we have
out there that uh really need to be
fixed in order to maintain lisaki so
with that we'll open up with any
question and the average age of uh state
owned dams are anywhere from 100 to 200
years old I mean we just did a uh
failure analysis at B Lake Dam over in
statford which is 192 years old and so
it's not uncommon for us to be dealing
with structures that were built in the
1800s that are really still in the same
configuration as they were in the
1800s thank you Mr
Clark question representative Dunn thank
you Mr chair thank you guys for being
here today really appreciate it one of
the things that the committee came up
with was to have you guys help us
educate the body and I feel like
somewhere that that got lost so we're
executing this bill next week and I
would say the majority of this committee
doesn't even know how important most
these dams are and how much impact they
have on the local economy so um I don't
know if it's too late or not but if you
guys one of the things that we had
talked about was you guys educating this
body and the finance committee as to how
important this is because this bill is
needed but in this environment of
economic if we don't educate the people
they're not going to vote for this so um
you know and you guys have any plans to
educate the body to help them understand
the importance of this and how it
affects their local
economy so I I've certainly been
presenting anytime I've been invited in
um science technology and energy um I
did a presentation to that that B that
committee on on this very issue and
there's also been several other
different not legislative organizations
but outside organizations that we've
been really trying to push this message
through
again similar similarly we're we're uh
we'll make ourselves available to any
and all uh one thing I think we talked
about in committee is Maybe if but I
think we would need a sponsor to do that
if you want to have a general session
available someday at repa we' be happy
to do that too uh so any and all of
that yeah follow follow up um the timing
might not be good for that but um I
think education will help the body
understand how important this is because
I would be willing to bet you that the
majority of the Reps here don't even
know the lakes that have dams and how
important it is to the local economy so
um you know education is always a good
thing and if we could get together and
do that I'd be happy to to do that but I
know we have a short time frame before
this is exact so but thank you guys for
coming presentation you mentioned you
make is it on PowerPoint
slides less than 100 slides yes okay
maybe you want to send your PowerPoint
presentation to the committee not that
everybody's going to everybody's going
to watch it but at least then you'll
have that you can click through it um
then you can contact these gentlemen if
you have any specific questions before
next
week representative
ghoul you need to put your mic down and
turn it
on yes I don't have a question but maybe
have a good editorial in some of the
newspapers so that everybody knows about
it maybe can you know do
something good idea any other questions
for the Reps we'll go to Mr Taylor then
representative Darby thank you Mr
chairman thank you for the question I
have many leaks in my district and one
of them has a dam Authority which pays
uh to state so much a year slake oopy
two of the three towns that B on the
lake would that Dam Authority and the
this so that that that is a unique
situation that we have over there on
Lake oy with the the authority over
there um that the the re the the income
that we get from that Authority my
understanding is that that really just
helps provide some of the on-site
operation that we have to do out there
but unfortunately what we're seeing at
Lake oopy while we did invest over $6
million on one part of the two dams that
are required out there the other Dam out
there needs significant Rehabilitation
work as well so we're going to be
looking at somehow funding probably
upwards of four to5 million in
renovations that that other side of the
dam is also going to require sometime in
the near future is capital budget yes
and and the uh the one that we repaired
several years ago the 6.5 million that
was all capital Appropriations that took
place for that none of the um none of
the um um
not not the association but what you had
mentioned previously The Authority thank
you represent
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question thank you for being
available today um I have a question on
uh the taxability of the land um the way
I read the this bill it says all taxable
waterfronts we heard um uh the prime
sponsor say that um current use wouldn't
be uh included but current use is taxed
land so it seems to me that this um
assessment would be um made by
Department of Environmental Services so
how do you interpret that s that this
bill so on on that front um I know there
are certain questions coming up about
what's you know what's taxable what's
not taxable conservation land current
land use things of that nature uh one
thing that we do believe that would help
us um as part of this is having
rulemaking Authority we do think we have
that Authority Under 42 uh col 87 as far
as being able to make rules within the
chapter of 42 which the fee would be
included however certainly including the
rule making Authority within the bill
would help bolster that and allow us to
have a process not only of what land
would be taxable but how about how
exactly we go about determining the
actual linear footage on each parcel and
and things of that nature
so follow up thank you again Mr chair
thank you for that answer um so the $158
per square per foot um can you talk talk
about how that was computed and if it
would if it included the land that is
use
so the way that was computed is um
similar legislation came about in in
2009 under HB 490 at that time and that
legislation they looked at what exactly
would the linear footage be and it was
roughly over 6 million linear feet of
shorefront is on the 276 bodies of water
created by state owned dams and of that
uh a little over a I think 1.4 million
is um is roughly uh what they felt was a
tax exempt and at that time it was non
nonprofits so for example the um uh
Grafton pond in in Grafton New Hampshire
owned by the state the dam is owned by
the state of New Hampshire that
majority of the shorefront around that
is um owned by a nonprofit that was not
included in the in the in the value and
so the actual in 2009 when we looked at
this the actual value of uh taxable
shorefront was about
4,790 uh, linear feet would be actually
taxable so if you take that value you
multiply by the dollar 58 C cents you
come up with uh roughly a little over
$7.5 million of Revenue potential that
would come out
obviously once the program is built we
would go ahead reanalyze all this so
those numbers would likely fluctuate to
some degree but that's that's a ballpark
and that is what the committee used um
to make their
assessment representative
Donnelly thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um I know in Sal
we have the milville dam that's actively
actively being rebuilt right now and the
the taxpayers had to we a grant from
Dees and then the taxpayers also had to
fund a bond how many of these types of
dams do you see long term do you say a
bond being created where then you can
use some of this money and it pays off
bonds how does how does this work for de
with your
dams so historically going back um to
when the dam in fund was originally
created there were um bonds associated
with that um I believe those have since
been paid off in in entirety uh so
really as of over the past 20 years ever
since we started having returning
uh drops in return in revenue on the dam
maintenance fund and we've been
switching to Capital funds really as of
right now we solely rely on Capital
funds for all our major repair projects
so to answer your question could there
be some kind of bonding that that could
take place quite possibly but I'm I'm
just not familiar enough with the state
front any other questions for our
speakers representative Sergeant thank
you Mr chairman do you know how many
households or or properties are
Downstream of these dams that benefit
safety-wise from their
upkeep so there Downstream of uh State
own own dams is there's likely thousands
of properties that would be affected if
if state owned dams failed um thousands
of Road Crossings as well however of
that inventory of 276 stams there's only
27 that are actually flood control
structures so the vast majority of these
roughly 90% of all of these dams are not
made for flood retention purposes and so
really what that means is that that
Dam there would likely be less of a risk
to those Downstream individuals if that
Dam wasn't in place because that dam is
there the water body is created the
threat is created if that dam was
removed those Downstream people would
not have that Upstream threat so like I
said there are roughly 27 flood control
sites that act truly as flood control
sites the Imp the dams are very large in
relation to their actual empowerment um
and those dams they fill up during a
storm event similar to um as many of you
are probably familiar with Franklin
Falls Dam owned by the US Army Corps of
Engineers hopkington Everett Dam Army
Corp of Engineers they they act in a
similar function we have about 12
roughly a dozen up in the baker River
Valley another dozen down in the sou
heagan River Valley and a couple other
scattered throughout but like I said the
vast majority of all of our dams are not
made to work in that
function and if I could the uh the
number below the dams continues to
increase as population fills in and that
type of thing so we we that also results
in the number of high Hazard Dam
actually increasing even though the dam
itself didn't change but the people
behind it
changed yeah and just just on that front
like in in 2004 we had um 30 33 High
Hazard dams now we have 64 it's not
because we're building new dams it's
because more development is occurring
Downstream so you have dams that were
once a lwh hazard Dam designed and built
to serve that purpose houses are built
Downstream the classification of that
Dam then changes now that Dam has to be
rebuilt to meet High Hazard criteria
which is which is a much higher
threshold for ability to manage a storm
event the ability to manage its
stability things of that
nature any other
questions one followup thank you Mr
chairman I'm just trying to draw the
distinction between why the fee the
Shoreland uh Waterfront fee is is
limited to people on the water so I hear
it for the 250 dams that are simply
there to create the body of water and
not for flood control but what about for
the 27 dams that do create flood control
and benefit the downstream properties
why were those Property Owners do do
know why they were eliminated from
consideration of paying something
upkeep I don't want to speak for the uh
the committee that looked into this but
um really it was it was solely focused
on and even even these flood control s
provide some kind of benefit so for
example there's a there's a flood
control site dam was built for flood
control but it um it also has uh has
development around it as well um and
there's also another site that has
drinking water purposes as well so there
are still people benefiting from those
those impoundments so yes you could say
there are Downstream communities that
benefit as well in fact um New Hampshire
has been working with the AG's office
and trying to figure out those benefits
with the state of Massachusetts because
certainly the Army Corps sites provide a
benefit not only to the residents of New
Hampshire but to the state of M the
residents of Massachusetts so the
Attorney General's office that's been a
long ongoing process working on that but
um I I think the committee wanted to
wanted to focus on who truly is is
benefiting from the vast majority of
these
empowerments anyone else Mr
Taylor your comments about the folks
Downstream from high Hazard dams are
they aware of the change of situation
that they are in high Hazard and uh are
they being impacted uh with flood
insurance
accordingly
so so when when there's a a house
Downstream of a high Hazard Dam and say
they they we we have to do so as part of
managing all these projects we have to
do all the emergency action plans which
include all the mapping necessary and
everything else to figure out who
exactly is Downstream of these when
those maps are created
um they not only get distributed to uh
to the dam safety program at Dees but
also they get distributed to Homeland
Security all the state police local
police and everything else so should
there be a an incident they every the
locals and everybody else can respond
accordingly there are times that those
Downstream people find out that they are
um within a inundation area but not not
necessarily there's certainly no
requirement on home sales or anything
else to notify that you were living
Downstream of a high Hazard Dam nor do
the uh FEMA flood insurance Maps reflect
that so when when flood insurance maps
are created they're created based on a
storm event moving through a particular
river system not necessarily on a dam
failing within that river system so when
we when we hear about flood insurance
and those people who live within flood
areas designated by FEMA it doesn't take
into account uh whether or not that is
because if there's a dam Upstream or not
um there are a couple of sites that are
um that are originally built by Army
Corps in which uh I can one for example
there's a site over in Farmington not
owned by the state it's actually owned
by the town of Farmington but it's a
levy system in
which in order for the people Downstream
of that Levy not to have to pay flood
insurance the town of Farmington has to
upkeep that Levy in order in order to
make sure that those people are exempt
from flood insurance but there's no
program that is that is because it's an
Army Core site there's no program like
that for State
sites so gentlemen I have one question
and poor Mr Bird's waiting to talk but
um I know this committee has had bills
before relating to Dam
decommissioning um I'm sort of amazed
that the percentage 250 or just to
create water and only 27 are to stop
floods what if we decommissioned all 200
50 dams you lower the water level and
then that would save like $60 million to
have to repair them and replace them has
that been looked at by this committee
your commission or anybody just a
question I'll let Cory answer but real
real quick uh yes we if the
communities in the legislature would
accept that I would say two things
ultimately a dam is is is here we're
talking hundreds of years and that as I
think we're we're talking about about is
and the operation and maintenance is is
absolutely essential so this is a gift
that keeps on giving so I agree in a
vacuum removing dams like that would be
in the long term the cheapest way to go
but I will say even doing that cost
millions of dollars and our experiences
in the local communities and this you
know it is what it is uh there's a lot
of resistance to change like that to to
those empowerments going away again we
gave you some statistics on the the
amount of the water levels going down
remember
with the influx of folks most of those
water body empowerments have people
living on the water and they seem to
eject they don't like to have mud flats
they like to have the water I think so
so I I'm just stting the obvious that's
a I was smirking because that's kind of
a political question right are you how
much pain are you willing to endure but
uh but I but overall in a vacuum we
actually absolutely do think that's the
right answer uh for the long-term uh
cost if in a vacuum yes I understand and
didn't we have a bill follow up yes you
may um didn't we have a bill I think a
year or two years ago about uh selling
some of these dams to the local towns
that wouldn't eliminate our problem to
get them repaired right it just would
take it off the state and put it on the
towns correct I'm in favor of that
certainly I thought you might be all
right any other
questions no okay thank you very much to
both of you appreciate it Mr birdie now
you're up you've been waiting patiently
much thank you Mr chairman and I
apologize but uh my legacy is uh right
Church wrong Pew and I've done it more
than once it's embarrassing when when
you go to an airport and to get on a
flight and you're a day early it's even
more embarrassing when you're a day late
and I've done both so uh I I previously
for members of the committee I who might
not have been here I I began my remarks
by saying that um kind of a dual role uh
I'm filling in for Jason stock executive
director of the Timberland Owners
Association and you have testimony from
him um I served as a president of the
association uh in the past and presently
I am on the policy committee and U we
you have our response that Jason has
written so thank you uh and I would try
to answer any of your questions it may
be in that but again um it's kind of the
recommendations of the and the in the uh
position of the Timberland owners I I'm
here today uh representing uh myself but
as as a Forester and I'm also a
selectman and presently chair of the
board uh in rney New
Hampshire uh I am a a licensed Forester
and uh and in the past managed several
thousands of Acres of Woodland uh
throughout the state uh presently I only
uh manage one major client uh my Farmer
firm is still active in and in managing
land throughout the state uh the one
client that I'm here to discuss um owns
land uh throughout the state presently
about
17,500 Acres of
Timberland um stretching from West
Stewarts down kind of a triangle over to
new dorham and Alton and then over to
Hill in Danbury and within that triangle
uh they own and manage as I mentioned
17,500 acres of land of which
approximately one half is in
conservation easement and currently uh
we are looking at placing another uh 470
acres in eement in Campton B and I will
get back to that and an additional uh
1500 acres is under
consideration um the property that I've
mentioned uh in Campton uh has Campton
bog on it uh we I've been working on
this easement uh since
1989 um the original application was
turned down for the lack of funding
although it was heavily supported uh by
uh fishing game uh for the habitat of of
mammals but also very important uh
location of the bog it supports a very
active native trout
population three major tributaries into
Campton bog uh come through our property
and so this land is under uh
consideration and should be closed on
sometime in in the late summer or early
fall
2025 uh the property that we have
consists of about depending on how you
measure it and I I bear your Indulgence
I became aware of this bill on on Monday
afternoon so I don't have any prepared
comments but I was able to extract some
information on the U amount of land with
water Frontage uh and it it is about
over 7,000 ft of standing water and in
high water times it's about 10,200
ft we have another property or the Green
Acres does in uh
went with through Hampshire on the
outflow of Lowa Baker Pond which we have
an additional 3,200 feet the impact if I
read this bill correctly and again uh I
I ask for Indulgence because I just was
became aware of it but the impact the
financial impact of this on on Green
Acres Woodland is a
minimum of
$16,600 a year
and if all the Wetland is considered
it's
20,700 uh dollars per
year I'm not in I'm not against the
importance of taking care of the dams I
think it's been well representative and
presented to to but I am I I the impact
is financially killing we are putting an
easement on Campton bog for several
purposes
one is the protection of critical
habitat for for mammals and fish but
also uh theyve giving up the development
potential outside of the of the bog um
which is quite valuable it's upin
Highwood hardwood and they're they're
getting rid of any uh commercial or
residential improvements that could be
made to it so what we have is a a parel
of land uh about a third of which is
impacted as either Wetland or standing
water and the remainder is we can't
develop it uh we have had several Timber
Harvest on this property over the last
40 years and presently we're standing
with a a a divers uh timan ranging in ag
is from about 4 five years uh 5 years
old to 40 years old the next major cut
will be in about 20 years so there's
really not a lot of income from this
property
and uh the taxes where it's under
current use is about uh $2 an acre a
year um the barain its total is about
470 Acres so you can do the math that
taxes are about $8 or $900 a year um
believe me this will be a killer so I I
I'm just really have a lot of concern
about the way this has been structured
we're about a half a mile to 34 of mile
with the standing water in yes you could
get a canoe into the water but You' be
dragging it through a lot of land and
this land is open for the public will be
open for the public it's open for
snowmobiling it's open for hunting and
it's open for fishing of which quite
frankly the client gets no income from
it it's free to the to the public
so I think and I don't know how other
people who have land similar to ours was
are going to be impacted but that is a
lot of
money in 10 years that's $200,000 if you
go with a higher or
$160,000 in 10 years and uh that is not
financially feasible uh for for them to
retain this land uh maybe the state
would like to buy it and we've had
support on the with fishing game on
working with them on the easement along
with the forest Society so I I think a
careful analysis uh of where this money
is coming from and how it's impacting it
and I I recognize there may be people
that do have a a benefit from the dams
will have cabins on it or have
approaches for for their docks and so
forth but I think this is is going a
little bit much and I I I think that it
requires a little bit more study of how
this is going to impact several land
owners whose land are in current use and
have no intention of probably ever
developing it and have no use of it
other than having the benefit of having
water Frontage so I thank you for your
Indulgence and I'll try to watch my
schedule a little bit better next time
any questions for Mr
birdie representative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
just I want to be clear you your client
has property that's on a
an impoundment that has correct it's a
with a with a state owned Dam and on
this empowerment as well are other
cabins and other um you know Residential
Properties is we got two properties that
I know of uh one is in Wentworth on just
on the outflow of lower Baker Pond
there's 3200 running feet along along
that and then Campton bog is depending
on how what is wet land and what is
water Frontage standing water is about
about 70 7200
ft and and then if you take the wet area
that certain times of year it's over
10,000 ft and as I read the bill as I
understand it again U it the variation
that minimum is about
$16,600 on the two properties I noted it
could be as high as $20,000 a year
that's the annual
payment followup thank you Mr chair
so um if the you know if the dam was
removed what's the impact to your uh
line the impact would be
minimum the impact would be uh would a
long ways toward destroying the habitat
for Native
Trout Brook Trout thank
you anyone else for Mr
birdie sing none thank you Mr birdie
thank you very much appreciate
it I think this says in support of the
waylander could be Jonah it Jonah yeah
okay my my clerk didn't correct you
that's my poor
handwriting so I apologize for that Mr
chairman no thank you for coming here
representative oh thank you very much
favor go ahead for the record my name is
Jonah Orion wheeler I represent the
towns of Peter bro and Sharon it's good
to see friends colleagues on the
resources Recreation and development
committee so thank you for having me
here today uh before I get into my brief
testimony I just want to answer a few
questions for people as they had it uh
to your question regarding the
uh 27 flood control dams and how the
committee decided whether or not to tax
the people that weren't on waterfronts
the committee did look at that and the
if the gates are open it removes that
flood risk from those people Downstream
so the committee the study committee had
determined that because those gates are
most often open they don't benefit
necessarily from those dams and
therefore wouldn't be a part of that
structure uh the second thing that I'd
like to address is the concerns of the
testifier before me uh if we give Dees
The rulemaking Authority in this bill
then they would have the leeway to be
able to determine which of those
properties are hash out all those
details that he had he had concerns with
and I think Dees is more than willing to
hash out those details and are looking
forward to doing that um Mr chairman I'm
here because those dams are in critical
condition and are a important piece to
the economy of our state the Lakes the
waterfronts the fish and the Fisheries
the swimming and the canoeing there's a
lot of money uh probably an
indeterminable amount that is brought in
to our economy from these dams and I
would be concerned with moving forward
as decommit with decommissioning as a
solution you know how silly is it that
we have these dams here from the mid 18
late 1800s that haven't been addressed
in so long uh I think it's just time for
us to find some fee structure and way to
address these dams and representative
dun thank you so much for your hard work
on this piece of legislation and
representative leechman he's too humble
uh he has served as chair of division
one
for uh a long time now and and has been
on the finance committee for a long time
and is someone who's at least tries to
be very careful with the money and so I
would when he comes forward with
something which has money in it I I uh
am generally supportive of it because I
know he's done his due diligence to make
sure that this is fiscally responsible
for the State of New Hampshire
representative leishman has put hundreds
of hours of work into this piece of
legislation as you have as well
representative done and I hope there's
some way to help educate the committee
and I would hope any of you who are
interested in the study committee report
would go to the for floor and and ask an
Fitzgerald to take you into the room
where all those study committee reports
collect dust and uh read that report
because I think it was well put and I
think they did a very good job on that
study committee so I'm here today to
testify on this damn bill because it's a
damn important
one and I hope that all of you will see
that and find some way to give Dees
rulle making Authority and make sure
that we can pass this for the safety of
our constituents here in the state of
New Hampshire thank you Mr chairman any
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your
testimony in opposition to the bill
Robert Johnson II I
think New Hampshire Farm
Bureau thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Rob
Johnson representing the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau as a federation's policy
director and administrator New Hampshire
Farm is a Federation of new hampsh New
Hampshire's 10 County farmer
organizations made up of just under 2500
Farm families supporters and Associate
Associated business owners and yes as
the chair has said that we are opposed
to the bill as drafted for the reasons
have been mentioned um we've reviewed it
and we uh failed to see as was mentioned
by the sponsor where uh open space lands
with an easement whether it be under
current use or a or some type of uh
conservation easement are Exempted it
simply says read line 25 upon show line
upon all taxable waterfronts maintained
um
that I guess I'll jump to the piece on
the ru making um for you to leave in Ru
making We Believe would be huge mistake
um I can't believe it's a mine that the
department wants to go into enter
especially developing rules to raise
funds for their own agency that's
language that should be in this bill if
that if if those lands are
exempt
um we have the one of the bigger qu big
questions our members had as well is the
need to clarify is what is impounded
water under the under the the taxable
water front um as far as as you is
probably aware uh that the state's Prime
Farmland is concentrated along along our
River corridors uh we have we have uh
farmers in the state that that own uh
you know considerable Frontage on those
rivers and you know a quarter mile of
Frontage is an assessment of over $2,000
a year which which our our Farmers
cannot grow enough you know corn and
crop stuff to cover something like that
that that that needs to be clarified uh
to give you an example I was reading in
some of the the uh Department of
literature where talking about the the
uh pasca quog which uh river which is
over in New Boston area and it and it it
read There was language said it was uh
the dam over there one of the dams was
classified as impounding close to six
six miles of of the river so that that
is there is a some type of
classification of impounded water on
these these rivers from what I what I
understand and uh again just to
reiterate that our the the open space
lands the state are not deriving the
same benefit as as some you know
especially the recreational users are
are benefiting from um there's a and
they they they cannot justify a return
uh based on the additional uh tax
revenue not to mention that the the
water quality benefits of open land
along these shorefront the the tourism
provides to the state is as as U as well
as recreational opportunities and I I
thank you for attention I'll leave it at
that thank you Mr chair any questions
for the
testimony Matt Ley from the forest
Society it doesn't say if you're opposed
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr chair
yet and I'm not trying to evade that
question um and I'll explain in just a
second but you know we understand that
the problem this bill
is attempting to address is a major
problem for our state and representative
leean noted the total cost to fix these
dams I mean that's a staggering amount
so we know that but we do have
we have a concern and a question you
know the concern is really um and Mr
birdie already talked about that and so
did raw but you know land that is
undeveloped open um that's you know AB
buts the Shoreland or near Shoreland you
know those types of properties do
provide really important ecological
environmental benefits for you know
flood
mitigation you know helping to sort of
protect and and you know the the Water
Resources whether um you know in the
ground or you know from that water body
so you know those types of properties
are very important and our concern is
that the way the bill is structured you
know we may be unintentionally creating
disincentives for you know a land owner
to maybe put their land in some type of
you know open space status whether with
an easement or just in current use um so
we are concerned about that point and
secondly is really the question of you
know what properties would be subject to
this fee and I I do agree with
representative Darby you know our read
of the build is that you know land and
current use would be subject um to the
fee and again you know are we going to
again have that
unintentional um impact on on what we're
trying to do to you know to keep some
Land open and undeveloped near these
really important water bodies
um and just speaking for the fores study
so we are a nonprofit um although but we
have chosen actually to put the land we
own in current use status and sort of
what is not clear to us because there is
actually you know for a
nonprofit there's not a sort of
automatic exemption to that tax status
they have to you know proactively apply
to the local town you know for tax
exempt and so but we have chosen to put
our land in current use instead of you
know exempting it from taxes and we're
not clear if the bill you know how our
property or how we would be treated um
since we do put it in current use and
therefore we are taxable um but we're
also a nonprofit so we're just not I
guess not clear um how ultimately we
would be treated under the bill so you
know we would urge the committee Tobe
try to address these these points but
I'll be happy to take any questions any
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
this is my last pink card opposing the
realtor thank you chair thank you
committee U my name is Sarah Holland I
am a real estate broker in central New
Hampshire and I'm the current chair of
the public policy committee for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors the
Realtors oppose this bill
um imposing a tax base on Shoreline
Frontage for properties benefiting from
State maintain dams raises several
concerns regarding private property
rights Equitable Taxation and the
distribution of benefits so targeting
only waterfront property owners for Dam
maintenance funding is inequitable as it
disregards the broader community that
benefits from the Dam's existence
including recreational users and
businesses that gain from tourism and
Water Resources dams provide advantages
that extend beyond adjacent Property
Owners such as flood control
recreational opportunities and
ecological benefits funding their
maintenance should be a collective
responsibility not solely born by a
subset of property owners introducing a
per foot Shoreline tax adds an
additional Financial strain on property
owners potentially leading to increased
it will in increase property taxes and
make ownersh ownership less affordable
and implementing this tax could set a
precedent for additional levies on
property owners for public
infrastructure leading to further
erosion of private property rights and
increased financial obligation without
corresponding individual benefits and
last year I was here in front of this
committee for some other Shoreland bills
um and I just want to reiterate that
this is not just the large more affluent
homes on water bodies these are a lot of
folks like you and I that are struggling
to pay our tax bill every single time
that it comes out so for these reasons
Realtors oppose HB 629 thank you for
your time and I'm happy to take any
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you I don't have any
other pink cards uh representative
Sergeant on the internet and the blue
card
online seven in favor 26 opposed on the
blue sheet two opposed one neutral thank
you so seeing no one approaching the
desk I will close the hearing on HB 629
FM and immediately open the hearing on
HB 644 FN relative to flying drones in
state parks and rec recognized
representative post the prime sponsor as
she approaches the
resources thank you Mr chair I always
love coming back to my roots um this
bill has been put through um I believe
for the third time um this bill allows
for commercial and recreational use of
drones or small unman aircraft in the
state park subject to exceptions and
limitations and establishes fees and
authorizes fines to be assessed for
violations and I would
um uh I would um like to turn this over
to uh Drew Melman who has um a wealth of
knowledge about this that I wouldn't be
able to answer but there are things that
have changed uh since the last two um
bills we put in on this and um I think
we um might be able to do something
about it this time for hobbyists and um
I would like to allow him to come up
well before he comes up any questions
for the representative or she's
deferring I am deferring okay thank you
record uh Drew mcalmont Hollis New
Hampshire thank you Mr chair for once
again giving me the opportunity to speak
before this committee my name is Drew
melmont I'm a data scientist for IBM and
I'm from Hollis New Hampshire I'll try
to keep my remarks brief since I've
testified at length on this topic the
last several years and have included
more information in my written testimony
to give you some background in my
license Private Pilot with over 250
hours as well as one of the first
licensed commercial drone pilots in the
United States I have deep ties to the
New Hampshire Aviation community and I'm
from a family of Pilots my dad is a
pilot my younger brothers are both
Pilots my uncle is a pilot my
grandfather was a pilot lots of pilots
from about the age of eight I've been a
model airplane or drone pilot and many
times I'd fly on state Parkland so this
would have been in the early 2000s in
2020 it came to my attention that New
Hampshire State Park Ed posting
information and signage outright Banning
drones that kicked off my Outreach to
several legislators including
representative Lisa post and
Representative Keith Ammon who are both
sponsors of this current bill HB
644 in the spirit of keeping this
concise I'm going to make seven key
points number one there's effectively no
permitting process for launching and
Landing drones in state parks no matter
what you hear in other testimonies this
is a blanket drone bin as a knee-jerk
reaction to drone Dr number two the
White Mountain National Forest allows
drones on most of its land provided that
the pilot has the correct certifications
and follows the Federal Aviation
regulations also known as the fars and
there's a streamlined permitting process
for commercial use the spirit of this
bill HB 644 parallels the national
forest
policies many states uh number three
many states already allow drones in most
or some state parks this includes
California Utah Texas Colorado
Pennsylvania Washington Oregon and
Alaska a blanket drone ban is an insult
to the Live Free or Die state number
four the state cannot regulate Federal
airspace the state can only regulate
launching and Landing drones any attempt
to put altitude restrictions would
likely lead to legal trouble in 2017 the
FAA sued the city of Newton
Massachusetts because the city attempted
to regulate Federal drone
airspace number five people are already
using drones in New Hampshire state
parks there are hundreds of videos on
YouTube of drone flights in New
Hampshire state parks let's regulate and
keep this activity safe number six we
allow hunting in New Hampshire state
parks which is both noisier and
considerably more dangerous than drones
Hampshire and lastly number seven I want
to preserve the opportunities that I had
as a child for future Generations drones
are an excellent education opportunity
for children in a great way to spark
interest in stem Fields therefore I ask
the committee to support an ought to
pass recommendation on HB 644 thank you
and I'm open to any questions questions
speaker I'm going to ask the question of
Mr Darby and then we'll go to you
representative Orion thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
question um as a um commercial uh drone
um pilot are and licensed drone pilot
are you interested in um the licensure
like license getting a license to um
launch these or are you interested in
this from a um U sort of a hobby
perspective because this bill seems to
do both permit per permit hobbyists and
provide for some licensure
licensing yeah My ATT is both uh
primarily this is a hobby for me I like
to take photos and um for non-commercial
use post them and save them and hang
them up on my wall but um these are two
use cases for drones and we do need to
have um rules for for both cases and I
do have the license and I do want to
have that ability to also take part in
well representative Ryan I said I'd go
to you next thank you Mr chair I just
would like to say I appreciate your
cleaning up that bill this makes it um a
whole lot more um easier to understand
and answered all those questions that we
had before thank you representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question uh is there
maximum Deo level uh under any
regulation if not what is the average
decimal level of a good siiz drone it
can be anywhere
thank you for the question it can be
anywhere from 60 to 70 DB so it's
usually less than traffic noise outside
and in comparison I don't have the sheet
in front of me but on my written
testimony I believe I have the the
decibel number for for guns it's it's
much higher it's more like 90 to over
100 Debs depending on how close you
are any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you uh Brian Wilson
Wilson good afternoon Mr chairman
committee members my name is Brian
Wilson I'm the director of the division
of Parks and
Recreation um I'm here today to provide
some testimony on behalf of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources and the division of Parks and
Recreation uh we uh would respectively
uh like to provide you with the
following information when reviewing new
or competing uses in state park lands
the dncr considers the recreational
experience of visitors in state parks
campgrounds and trails protecting the
quality of that experience is one of the
purposes of our administrative
rules with respect to the impacts of
drones on other recreationalists I asked
the question of what potential impact
would a drone have on other recreational
users who are otherwise expecting to be
able to enjoy a quiet experience in
Parks campgrounds or Trails our
administrative rules governing the use
of the department lands include rules
relative to uh Public Access uh the
quiet enjoyment of uh recreational use
of the property by others or budding
land owners not being dis uh Disturbed
um degreg of the visitor experience um
and uh and and and others although this
bill provide uh prohibits flights that
intentionally interfere with the
reasonable use and enjoyment of the park
by others the definition of this
provision is unclear and
unenforceable the bill also prohibits
the use of drones with the intent to
conduct video surveillance of private
citizens in state parks without prior uh
consent of the persons being surveilled
we believe that this pres uh provision
is also unenforceable and that a
visitor's privacy could be
unintentionally
impacted with respect to commercial use
um we have already in place a process
that grants drone use with the issuance
of a special use permit through our
administrative rule process um within
the testimony that I provided our
several examples of just uh permits that
we have issued within the last year uh
for individual or groups um who have um
SE seek permission uh to operate a drone
within State Park
bounds the bill uh further authorizes
the department to charge a retrieval fee
of not more than
$100 this fee may not fully cover the
cost of Staff time that would take staff
away from their regular duties and
responsibilities from our Park visitors
additionally staff would be held liable
for damage of drones during retrieval
the bill authorizes the department to
charge a drone operator $25 per day for
flights that occur in state parks the
division of state parks is operationally
self-funded and as such um we are
authorized to set fees pursuant to RSA
a3g um through the fiscal committee's
approval and um that helps us to uh
maximize our revenues and adjust fees
accordingly to market conditions and
trends that are common practice in the
private
industry uh this bill circumvents the
Department's established procedures to
set fees for Access and use of of the
park system we respectfully request that
the rules related to the recreational
drone use in state parks be established
under our administrative rule process
and uh we would would request that any
fees related to drone use is established
um through our current uh process under
RSA 2116a uh that includes review and
approval of the fiscal committee thank
you for the opportunity to provide
testimony on this on this bill and I'm
happy to answer any questions you have
thank you Mr Wilson we'll start with
representative Sergeant then go to
representative Dupont thank you Mr
chairman um I have a lack of knowledge
of the current laws or regulations or I
guess State park rules on drones could
you let me know what is the current
state of the law um well I believe we
have somebody from the Department of
Safety to he to speak to um ongoing
Legislation during this session Rel
relative to the laws and uh when this
bill has been brought up in Prior
sessions uh as well to uh there was a
testimony from the Department of
Transportation uh relative to uh the
laws what we are strictly trying to
control and enforce is the um operating
and the The Landing or and um launching
within the bounds of the state parks as
was uh mentioned in previous testimony
here the control over what happens in
airspace is not our specialty um so it
is it is a challenge for us to keep Pace
with kind of ongoing with with with the
industry of that and uh you know the the
the kind of continuing prevalence of uh
demand for it so um I don't have a lot
of great specific answers relative
to that question sorry followup is it
allowed right now in state parks can you
land and take off a drone in the state
park you can you can through our
administrative rule process you can get
yes representative Dupont thank you Mr
chairman Mr Wilson who's responsible for
enforcing these
rules uh thank you for the question so
uh so um it's uh ultimately it it's the
responsibility of the park management
staff um in in this case they at uh
management staff that are placed at a
particular Park uh they're responsible
for reinforcing all of our rules uh of
of the park system um we have had
instances uh where we rely on the local
uh police force or fishing game or the
state police um when um there is lack of
compliance and our authority to um it um
enforce laws does not go very far so um
when we get to that kind of that test
point is when that's when we we bring in
law enforcement to help support
us yeah so for the benefit of those new
members on this committee because we've
had drone bills for many years my memory
and maybe um Mr Wilson can correct me if
I'm incorrect but it was
mentioned once the Drone which is an
unmanned They Don't Really call him
drone in statute unmanned
flight something um once it's in the sky
it's the FAA that has control over the
sky we have no control over the sky what
we were told last year was We can
control if we let them take off in the
park and launch but uh from what we had
testimony before if you're not in the
park you can be next to it on your
friend's land launch your drone and fly
it over the park and we have no control
over it the dncr doesn't have control
because it's in the sky am I correct
about that yes yes that's correct so
just so you know that we don't have
unlimited Authority once it's up in the
air um representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you um
for taking my
question
um sorry just blinked on my question so
um you previously went through rule
making for for this process um can you
talk about uh the um how you resulted at
um restricting it um uh restricting
takeoffs and landings um across all
state parks based on the public hearings
um so we are actually bringing that
through the rul making process right now
as we speak we are working on that so we
did a comprehensive revision uh to our
administrative rules um over the last
year or so and that will'll be be coming
forward Ward through uh the jail car
process here um over the next several
months um I believe we're looking at a
public hearing date um I I don't want to
say that I know I know it was in the
near future I think sometime in March so
so there's uh components relative to
that in terms of Outreach and
notification that we're working through
as we speak that prior to that being uh
drones we were working off of a a
department policy for that uh but to
further strengthen this relative to Dr
and other things that were not captured
through the administrative rules we were
operating at a on a policy level um so
we're we're working on incorporating
that language now C currently thank you
follow up thank you Mr chair
um is there um can you imagine a case
where um the policy is not sort of black
and white where um drone um UAV use is
allowed in some areas but not others you
know less uh you know less popular areas
something like that um well as with
every rule it's um never black and white
when it it it it something becomes
challenged and and you know we're trying
we attempt to enforce something um it is
literally usually on a case-by casee
basis relative to the nuances of that
particular example um a couple things
that I could say so uh one of the prior
speakers U mentioned uh that drone use
is allowed in US Forest Service property
that that is correct um however the
National Park Service has a different
policy where is they only allow it
through permitting so there the the
difference there is relative to
generally the the the expectation that
park space is going to be generally more
uh populated with people and and
recreators than an an open um you know
natural resources Back Country type uh
space like you like the White Mountain
National Forest for instance so um
that's where you know I could see you
know plenty of examples where there
there probably would not be a general
impact uh to regular visitors on you
know either a very quiet day in in a
state park somewhere or somewhere where
it's being operated discreetly or in the
back country we have other rules uh that
are like this as well too for instance
um walking pets off leash um that is
also something that that is permitted
within state parks but the the language
within the regulations speaks to
language around kind of remote areas and
such and and lack of people so it
becomes a judgment call um so and then
when that becomes a judgment call that
also becomes an issue for staff to you
know when to when that needs to be
enforced yeah any other questions from
Mr Wilson Mr
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your question broad my ignorance but
how many state parks are there and
What's the total acreage uh we have we
manage 93 properties across the state
and um between uh State Forest
reservations and State Park reservations
I believe it is approximately 250,000
Acres
yeah anyone else saying none thank you
Mr Wilson
you I have one more card uh Department
of Safety Christopher ball in opposition
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is Christopher ball
I'm here representing the department of
safety I'm a trooper uh employed by the
state police and I'm assigned to our
Aviation unit uh the reason I'm here
today is really just to bring forward um
potential uh issue or just something the
committee should be aware of when uh
considering this legislation going
forward um and I apologies if you
already aware of this but there are two
other bills one within the Senate SB 49
and one within the house uh House Bill
468 uh regarding the use of drones in
New Hampshire and specifically what that
legislation is going to speak to is to
defining uh crimes and penalties for
those who choose to use drones in a
nefarious way within New Hampshire um
prior to uh this and I think it's been
discussed lately here is that um law
enforcement New Hampshire hasn't had a
lot of um recourse um up until this
point uh to do anything with people that
might be using drones nefariously um for
illegal means either you know flying
them recklessly flying them in places
where they're restricted um generally
that's Fallen to the federal government
to enforce those rules and the hope is
with these two other uh bills being
proposed is that New Hampshire law
enforcement will have uh the recourse
one appropriate uh to take enforcement
action um based on violations of that
potential uh legislation so uh with that
just asking that um the language in this
current bill um at least be amended or
or just for consideration on the
committee's part here uh when going
forward to maybe have some wording in
there that would speak to uh drone
operators who would be taking off and
flying from state parks uh that they be
uh made aware or at least um somehow
written into the bill that they must
comply with with state laws as well and
I realize I might be getting ahead of
ourselves a little bit asking you to
address potential legislation that's in
different parts of uh the legislative
process right now but I think it's just
important that uh the commit is at least
aware of it uh and consider that
information uh as they move forward with
this bill I'd be happy to take any
questions pretty easy no questions for
the speaker thank you very much I don't
have any more pink cards is there anyone
else that wanted to speak on
HB 644 FN relative to flying drones in
the state parks don't see anybody
approaching the Mike and now
representative Sergeant online in the
blue sheets online 11 in support five
opposed blue sheets one in support one
opposed thank you very much I'm going to
officially close the hearing on HB 644
FN thank you representative post and I'm
going to go right into opening the
hearing on H B 657 FM relative to short
notice booking access for New Hampshire
residents to state
parks see Prime sponsor I believe is
representative Sellers and you're going
to present the bill representative thank
you Mr chair thank you committee me
Members my name is representative John
Bridgewater I'm going to make this real
easy
I'm going to ask you itl this bill
because of federal law stepping on us
we're not able to really go full with
the bill without us stepping all over
the state federal law so and and because
we actually get Federal money it's a
problem and therefore the bill is just
mut at this point so if you don't mind I
appreciate if you itl the bill thank you
very much
representative um Mr Wilson do you still
that so any questions for the
representative asking us to itl it
or Mr Wilson from
dncr don't see any so thank you very
much representative thank you Mr Wilson
so I don't see any more pink cards and
uh don't see anybody approaching the mic
but I'll ask anyone else to speak on HB
FN don't see anybody we go to
representative Sergeant for online in
the blue sheets we have online one
opposed One support blue sheet One
support one opposed and just for the
record if our senior minority leader was
here I'd probably ask if we could go to
exec and itl this but she's not here and
I said we wouldn't do that so I think
that'll be an easy one for us next week
when we this will be our eighth one for
next week so we'll hold it I appreciate
the representative uh coming forth to
ask us to itl it and other than that I'm
going to close today's hearings remember
we have both parties that will have
caucuses before next week we're going to
exec these eight bills at 10:00 and then
go into the final three hearings and
exec those in the afternoon so watch
your emails for any more information and
information about your caucus thank you
very much have a